ARCHULETA ADKINS BASE BACKER
FOR JESSE BRADFORD CABRERO
QUARTET THREE DALLY DODD
TORONTO EGGMAN GLAZER WHEN
SOLID GROSS HURTS BERG WEST SO
HER TADO. JONES CAN LONGER
LAYERED LEYVA THE MON MCGUIRE
MELINDA'S MEN NEWMAN NIELSEN A
TRAIL OF BOTH PAN FORTUNE TINO
ROSSI RUBIO SKINNER TURN ON
BERG WHITE HOUSE SKI WINNER
WELL. I THANK YOU MADAM
SECRETARY A QUORUM IS PRESENT
WITH THE MEMBERS AND OUR GUEST
ON THE RAIL AND IN THE GALLERY
PLEASE RISE WILL BE LED IN
PRAYER THIS MORNING BY SENATOR
WIENER AFTER WHICH PLEASE
REMAIN STANDING AND WILL BE LED
IN THE PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE TO
THE FLAG BY SENATOR- CHILL
ABOUT SENATOR WIENER THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT. COLLEAGUES LET
US PRAY TO BE GRATEFUL FOR WHAT
IS. TO FIND GOOD AMID THE
UNWANTED ASPECTS OF LIFE
WITHOUT DENYING THE PRESENCE OF
THE ON WANTED. TO BE PRESENT TO
ONE'S OWN SMALL SPACE WHILE
STRETCHING TO THE WIDE WORLD
BEYOND THE- TO SEARCH FOR AND
TO SEE THE GOOD IN OTHERS NOT
LOOKING FOR FAULTS AND
WEAKNESSES. TO BE THANKFUL FOR
EACH LOVING THE NO MATTER HOW
INSIGNIFICANT IT MIGHT APPEAR.
TO STRIVE TO BE LOVING AND
CARING AND SITUATIONS ARE
CONSISTENTLY CHALLENGED THESE
VIRTUES. TO BE AT PEACE WITH
WHAT CANNOT BE CHANGED. THIS WE
PRAY IN FAITH AMOND. THE
COLLEGE PLEASE JOIN ME IN THIS
RIVETING THE PLEDGE OF
ALLEGIANCE. I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE
TO THE FLAG. SHE SAID-
INDIVISIBLE WITH LIBERTY AND
JUSTICE FOR ALL. GOOD MORNING
MEMBERS WE HAVE SOME VERY
SPECIAL PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR
WE HAVE MANY INDIVIDUALS THAT
WE'RE GOING TO BE RECOGNIZED
THERE IN THE GALLERY GOOD
MORNING THANK YOU FOR BEING
HERE BY CAN NOW SENATOR MCGUIRE
TO PLEASE COME TO THE ROSTRUM
SO THAT I CAN HAVE THE HONOR OF
PRESENTING ONE OF THESE
RETIREMENT. RECOGNITIONS. ARE
THEY TEASING GENTLEMAN OF THE
SENATE. BETTER PRESS ANY
PREPARED TO PRESENT YES PLEASE
PROCEED THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT
GOOD MORNING MEMBERS IT IS MY
ABSOLUTE HONOR TO RECOGNIZE
TERRY OR TEASE A LONGTIME
SENATE STAFFER WHO PRIOR TO HIS
RETIREMENT EARLIER THIS YEAR
WORKED IN THE SENATE FOR OVER
THIRTY YEARS. TERRY ORTIZ WAS A
FIXTURE ON THE THIRD FLOOR OF
THE CAPITOL FOR MANY MANY YEARS
I KNOW YOU ALL REMEMBER TERRY
AS SENATE SERGEANT STAFF AS
WELL AS IN THE KITCHEN AND
COFFEE SHOP MANY OF US IN THE
SENATE FAMILY WERE ABLE TO GET
TO KNOW TERRY OVER THE YEARS.
TERRY'S QUICK WITH HIS STORIES
AND MOST IMPORTANTLY HIS
DEDICATION TO THIS INSTITUTION
MADE HIM A FAVORITE AMONG
SENATORS AND STAFF HAS
PRESIDENT PRESENCE IN THE
CAPITAL IT'S DEFINITELY MISSED
WE DO MISS YOU TERRY. WE
UNDERSTAND THAT TERRY IS
STAYING BUSY THESE DAYS WITH
HIS FAMILY DAY TRIPS GARDENING
READING UPCOMING ART CLASSES
AND VOLUNTEERING TO WORK WITH
ADULTS WITH DISABILITIES WE
ALSO UNDERSTAND THAT HE DOES
NOT MISS WEARING KHAKIS AND
DRESS SHIRTS AND HAVING TO KEEP
HIS HAIR CUT- THE- THE
TRAPPINGS OF RETIREMENT. WE'RE
SO GLAD TO HAVE HIM BACK TODAY
TO WISH HIM THE VERY BEST IN
HIS RETIREMENT JOINING TERRY IN
THE GALLERY AS HIS WIFE DEBBIE
SO LET'S GIVE THEM A ROUND OF
APPLAUSE AND CENTER YOUR BEST
WISHES FOR A HAPPY RETIREMENT.
MAYBE IT'LL BE HALF OF THE CITY
IT'S A VERY WELCOME. DEBBIE IN
THE GALLERY. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
COMMITMENT TO THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA WITH THE BACK OF THE
BOX WE'RE. I THINK IT'S A
REQUIRED NEXT UP IS SENATOR
WILL. WHO WILL BE HONORING
GENET GARDNER CENTER WELL.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT TODAY
IT IS MY PLEASURE AND HONOR. TO
RECOGNIZE GINNY GARDNER WHO IS
MY FORMER LEGISLATIVE DIRECTOR
AND DEPUTY CHIEF OF STAFF
RETIRED LAST DECEMBER. TODAY HE
HAD A LONG CAREER IN THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE WAS
RESPECTED BY ALL WHO KNEW HER.
AND WAS THE CONSUMMATE
PROFESSIONAL IF YOU GIVES ME
SOMETHING TO DO IT IS DONE ON
TIME AND DONE INCREDIBLY WELL.
SHE TOUCHED MANY LIVES AS A
CHIEF OF STAFF LEGISLATIVE
DIRECTOR FIELD REPRESENTATIVE
CALLED MENTOR MOST IMPORTANTLY
FRIEND. I FIRST MET TODAY AFTER
I GOT ELECTED TO THE SENATE
ACTUALLY MATTER OVER THE PHONE-
SHE LOVES TO TRAVEL SHE WAS
DOING INTERNATIONAL TRAVEL AND
EVERY TOLD ME YOU GOT A HIGHER
TODAY GARDNER GOT A HIGHER
TODAY GARDNER I WAS SO
IMPRESSED WITH HER THAT I
EXTENDED AN OFFER TO HER WHILE
SHE WAS IN BEIJING AND I WASIN
SANTA CLARITA CALIFORNIA AND
I'M SO HAPPY THAT SHE SAID YES.
I YEAH. SO HOW DID IT NOT ONLY
ORGANIZED AND RAN MY
LEGISLATIVE PACKAGE BUT SHE WAS
ALSO A POINT OF CONTACT FOR
MANY. CONSTITUENT INQUIRIES IN
LASER WITH LOCAL SCHOOL BOARDS
AND COMMUNITY COLLEGES. PRIOR
TO BEING PART OF MY TEAM TODAY
SERVED AS CHIEF OF STAFF TO
FORMER REPUBLICAN LEADER STATE
SENATOR BOB HUFF. WELL HE'S
BOTH IN THE SENATE AND THE
ASSEMBLY. PRIOR TO JOINING. MR
HOW STAFF TODAY WAS CHIEF OF
STAFF TO ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
PATRICIA BATES AND ANTI
PERSONALITY AS WELL AS A
LEGISLATIVE AIDE AND FIELD
REPRESENTATIVE TO SOME WOMEN
LARRY BOULDER. J. ENJOYS MANY
ACTIVITIES RELATED TO TRAVEL
THAT SHE JUST CAME BACK FROM
FRANCE MUSIC WHICH SHE HAS
AWESOME TASTE IN ANIMALS. ART
AND BELIEVE IT OR NOT POWER
BOATING IN FACT- TODAY SERVED
AS THE COMMODORE OF THE
SACRAMENTO YACHT CLUB IN TWO
THOUSAND AND TWELVE WHO'S ON
THE BOARD OF DIRECTORS FOR
SEVEN YEARS SHE'S A MEMBER OF
THE INTERNATIONAL ORDER OF THE
BLUE GAVEL IN ASSOCIATION A
LOCK AT. YACHT CLUB PAST
COMMODORES WE THANK HER FOR HER
SERVICE AND WE WISH HER THE
BEST IN HER RETIREMENT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU SENATOR
WELL. CONGRATULATIONS SERVICE
PLEASE HELLO FAURIA. NEXT UP IS
SENATOR BATES WHO W HOLD WHO
WILL BE TALKING ABOUT JON
BRESLER SENATOR BATES. AGAIN
SENATOR BATES. HELLO. YEAH ALL
RIGHT WE'RE WORKING ON IT OKAY.
IT'S GREEN. THE FINAL. THANK
YOU THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
AND CERTAINLY IT'S MY HONOR AND
PRIVILEGE TO RISE TODAY TO
HONOR A REAL INSTITUTION IN THE
SENATE REPUBLICAN CAUCUS JOHN
WRESTLER WHO RETIRED EARLIER
THIS YEAR AFTER A THIRTY YEAR
CAREER WITH THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATURE JOHN BEGAN HIS
CAREER IN NINETEEN NINETY
WITHIN A FAMILY MAN GM REALTY
WHERE HE SERVED IN A VARIETY OF
CAPACITIES INCLUDING A FIELD
REPRESENTATIVE THE CASE WORKER
SCHEDULER WRITER DISTRICT PRESS
DIRECTOR AND OFFICE MANAGER JIM
HAD HIM WORKING OUT VERY HARD.
JOHN MOVED WITH GM TO THE
SENATE IN NINETEEN NINETY SIX
WHEN JIM REALTY WAS ELECTED HE
WAS THERE IT WAS THERE THAT
JOHN PROPOSED BUDGETED MANAGED
THE CREATION OF SOME OF THE
FIRST WEB SITES IN THE STATE
SENATE AFTER JOINING THE CAUCUS
AS A CONSULTANT IN NINETEEN
NINETY SEVEN JOHN EXPANDED HIS
ROLE AS WEBMASTER BY DESIGNING
AND MANAGING WEBSITES FOR EVERY
SENATE REPUBLICAN THROUGH THE
YEARS JOHN HAS WORKED CLOSELY
WITH THE SENATE LEADERSHIP. IN
ANY COMMUNICATION DIRECTORS
PROVIDED INVALUABLE SUPPORT FOR
THE LEADERS AND MEMBERS. OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE LEGISLATURE.
JOHN HAS SERVED JOHN HAS EARNED
THE RESPECT. THROUGH HIS
SERVICE TO THIS INSTITUTION AND
WILL FOREVER BE PART OF THE
SENATE FAMILY JOIN ME IN
CONGRATULATING HIM ON HIS
RETIREMENT IN THANKING HIM FOR
HIS DECADES OF PUBLIC SERVICE
AND WISHING HIM VERY WELL AS HE
TAKES THESE INCREDIBLE
QUALITIES AND- ATTRIBUTES ONTO
HIS COMMUNITY FOR SERVICE. I
THINK I HAD A GREAT RESPONSE HI
CONGRATULATIONS JOHN. NEXT IS
MR REID AND SENATOR NIELSEN IS
GOING TO SAY A FEW WORDS.
MANAFORT IS LAYING DOWN THE
THESE ARE ACTUALLY FOR ME SAD
OCCASIONS BECAUSE I'VE- KNOWN
MOST ALL OF THESE PEOPLE. AND
THESE INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE
SERVED MANY YEARS IN THE
TRENCHES HERE BEING THE WIND
BENEATH OUR WINGS. ARE SO
DESERVING OF THAT RECOGNITION
AND OUR BEST WISHES IF THEY GO
ON TO OTHER ACHIEVEMENTS. DAVID
REED IS CERTAINLY ONE OF THE
EPITOME. OF THE POLITICAL
CONSULTANTS. AND CHIEF OF STAFF.
HE SERVED FOR DECADES AS A
TWENTY FOUR YEARS NOW HE HAS
BEEN AROUND HE DID RETIRE FROM
US- THE FIRST OF THIS YEAR.
HE'S WORKED FOR HIS FATHER IN
LAW BERNIE RICHTER. I STARTED
OUT IN THE POLITICAL CHANGES IN
CHICO GRADUATE OF SACRAMENTO
STATE. I WORKED WITH GALLAGHER
MYSELF THE MODEL. FOR AND
BERNIE BERNIE RICHTER. DAVID IS
AND THE REMAINS OF ONE OF THE
TOP POLITICAL MINDS IN
CALIFORNIA AS WE SPEAK HERE
TODAY HE'S BEING A PRINCIPAL
CONSULTANT FOR A FOR A
CANDIDATE FOR GOVERNOR. AND HE
WILL HAVE INDEED A LONG CAREER.
MOST IMPORTANTLY HE'S A VERY
DECENT HUMAN BEING. DEEP AND
ABIDING VALUES RESPECTED BY
REPUBLICANS AND DEMOCRATS ALIKE.
A PROUD FATHER. HIS WIFE
SUZANNE AND HE HAD BROUGHT INTO
THE WORLD. A SON AND A DAUGHTER.
MATT IS GOING TO BE A
PRACTICING ATTORNEY. THE
DAUGHTER MARRIED AND WORKING IN
THIS AREA HERE REGULAR USERNAME-
YOU WOULD NOT NEED TO WONDER
WHERE HER NAME CAME FROM. BUT
THEY'RE THEY'RE A SOLID FAMILY
SALT OF THE EARTH LADIES AND
GENTLEMAN. AND A CREDIT TO THIS
INSTITUTION. DAVID THE- WORKED
IN WORKING IN POLITICAL
PARTISAN ROLES. THE CHIEF OF
STAFF HE WAS RESTORED TO THE
SHIP AND VERY HELPFUL TO ME AND
MY PASSION FOR THE INTEGRITY OF
THE INSTITUTION AND THE RULES
OF THE INSTITUTION. AND A GOOD
MANAGER. THAT POLITICS IS OFTEN
SOMETHING THE SLACK. IT MIGHT
BE GOOD POLITICS BUT NOT ALWAYS
SO GOOD AT MANAGING. AND DAVID
WAS STEADFAST. ELICITED GREAT
RESPECT FROM THE CONSTITUENTS
OF RE REPRESENTED. INSTEAD FOR
OUR GOALS THE- CONSTITUENTS
FIRST. WELL ACTUALLY IT'S FAITH
FAMILY AND CONSTITUENTS- AND
DAVID ALWAYS UNDERSTOOD THAT.
DEVOTED TO HIS FAMILY IS IT
THAT'S ONE OF THE GREAT
TRADEMARKS OF DAVID REID. BUT
HE HAS LEFT HIS MARK. ON THIS
INSTITUTION AND WE WISH HIM
WELL AS HE GOES ON TO FURTHER
CAREERS THIS YOUNG MAN. WELL
HE'S GETTING A LITTLE OLDER
BUT- NOT AS OLD AS ME. AND HE'S
GOT MANY MORE CHALLENGES AHEAD
WE WISH HIM WELL AND HE HAS
ALWAYS BEEN AND WILL REMAIN A
CREDIT TO THE INSTITUTION HE SO
NOBLY SERVED. FOR SO MANY YEARS.
THANK YOU SENATOR NELSON AND
CONGRATULATIONS DAVID THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR YOUR SERVICES STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. MEMBERS MESSAGES
FROM THE GOVERNOR WILL BE
DEEMED READ MESSAGES FROM THE
ASSEMBLY WILL BE DEEMED READ
REPORTS OF COMMITTEE WILL BE
DEEMED RED AND AMENDMENTS
ADOPTED MEMBERS WERE MOVING TO
MOTIONS RESOLUTIONS AND NOTICES
THIS WOULD BE THE TIME TO PULL
BILLS FF OF CONSENT. AND I AM
GOING TO WAIT A MOMENT TO MAKE
SURE I GET EVERYONE I SEE
SENATOR BATES. PLEASE THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT AT THE REQUEST
OF THE AUTHOR I WOULD LIKE TO
MOVE FILES ITEM FORTY FOUR
ASSEMBLY BILL FOURTEEN TWENTY
SIX TO THE INACTIVE FILE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH SENATOR SENATOR
WILK THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
AT THE REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR
PLEASE REMOVE AB FIVE SIX FIVE
LACKEY WHICH IS FILE AND ONE
EIGHTY SEVEN FROM THE CONSENT
CALENDAR FOR THE PURPOSE OF THE
MENACE THANK YOU SENATOR WALKS
ANIMAL. THANK I. YOU FOR THE-
WE CAN'T HEAR YOU ONE MOMENT. I
DON'T THINK IT'S YOU PHIL
SPECTOR. HELLO HELLO THERE WE
GO THANK YOU THANK YOU I'D LIKE
TO PULL ITEM TWO TWENTY FOUR
EIGHTY SIX FORTY COOLLY FROM
THE CONSENT CALENDAR FOR
PURPOSES OF AMENDMENTS. THANK
YOU CENTER THE MON SENATOR
JONES. THE TEEN UP THE CONSENT
CALENDAR FOR THE PURPOSES OF
CHOPPING AMENDMENTS THANK YOU
SENATOR FIVE SIXTEEN THANK YOU
SENATOR WIENER I THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT REQUEST OF THE
AUTHOR- PLEASE PULL FILE ITEM.
TWO OH TWO EIGHTY FOURTEEN
FIFTY TWO TANKS FROM THE
CONSENT- CALENDAR FOR PURPOSES
OF AMENDMENT. THANK YOU SENATOR
WIENER CENTER LASER. AND ON
BEHALF OF THE AUTHOR I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THAT FILE
I DON'T. ONE THIRTY THREE
EIGHTY SEVEN SEVEN FIVE HE
MOVED AGAIN AFTER FIVE. THANK
YOU SENATOR GLAZER SENATOR
RUBIO. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT AT THE REQUEST OF THE
AUTHOR I WOULD LIKE TO PULL UP
ITEM NUMBER ONE EIGHTY NINE
EIGHTY SIX SEVENTY THREE FROM
CONSENT FOR THE PURPOSE OF
AMENDMENTS THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SENATOR SENATOR CABALLERO.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
PRESIDENT I'D LIKE TO ASK THAT
FILE NUMBER. TWO TWENTY FIVE
EIGHTY SIX NINETY FOUR BE
PULLED FROM CONSENT FOR
PURPOSES OF AMENDMENTS THANK
YOU CENTER CAREER CENTER DOT.
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT THE
EQUEST OF THE AUTHOR PLEASE
REMOVE THE FOLLOWING BILLS FROM
CONSENT. AND PLACE THEM ON
THIRD READING. ABC THIRTEEN
THIRTY THAT'S FILE ITEM NUMBER
TWO THREE TWO- AB FIFTEEN
EIGHTY NINE THAT'S FILE ITEM
NUMBER. TWO THREE SIX ALSO AT
THE REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR
PLEASE REMOVE THE FOLLOWING
BILL FROM CONSENT PLACE ON
THIRD READING. A. B. TWELVE
FORTY TWO FOLLOW ITEM NUMBER
ONE NINETY SIX THANK YOU
SENATOR DODD CENTER IT'S BERG.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WHEN
PRESIDENTS REQUEST THE AUTHOR
PLEASE PULL THE FOLLOWING FOUR
MEASURES THE FOLLOWING FOUR
MEASURES FROM THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. FIRST FILE ITEM ONE
SEVEN THREE. EIGHT B. SIXTY
THREE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER. PETER
NORRIS SECOND. FILE A NUMBER
TWO OH FIVE. ABC FIFTEEN
SEVENTY FOUR BY THE COMMITTEE
ON JOBS ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT IN
THE ECONOMY THREE. FILE ITEM
NUMBER TWO TWO SIX A. B. EIGHT
THIRTY BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER FLORA
FOR FILE ITEM NUMBER TWO TWO
NINE. EIGHT B. TEN THIRTIES TEN
THIRTY SEVEN BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
GRAYSON THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU SENATOR HERTZBERG
MEMBERS ANYTHING ELSE THAT YOU
WOULD LIKE TO HAVE PULLED FROM
THE CONSENT CALENDAR. THANK YOU
SEEING AND HEARING THEN WE'LL
MOVE TO CONSIDERATION OF THE
DAILY FILE WE'LL START WITH THE
SECOND READING FILE MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILLS 263-491-1120. FOUR TWELVE
EIGHTY THREE TWENTY TWO FIFTEEN
EIGHTY FIVE READING FILE WILL
BE DEEMED DREAD. WE'RE NOW
MOVING TO UNFINISHED BUSINESS
WE'RE GOING TO START WITH FIVE
ITEM TWENTY FOUR CENTER ARCH
ALETTA. MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE.
SENATE BILL THREE NINETY TWO BY
SENATOR ARCHULETA AN ACT
RELATING TO COMMON INTERESTS
INVOLVEMENTS CENTER CHULA THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT. I RISE
TODAY TO PRESENT SENATE BILL
THREE NINETY TWO WHICH IS BACK
ON CONCURRENCE SENATE BILL
THREE NINETY TWO WILL IMPROVE
ACCESSIBILITY TO IMPORTANT
DOCUMENTS TO REDUCE DELIVERY
COSTS BY REQUIRING HOMEOWNERS
ASSOCIATIONS TO COMMUNICATE
WITH HOMEOWNERS VIA EMAIL
UNLESS A RESIDENT CHOOSES TO
RECEIVE. COMMUNICATION VIA
ANOTHER METHOD SUCH AS
TRADITIONAL MALE AMENDMENTS
TAKEN IN THE ASSEMBLY REVISE A
BILL TO REQUIRE A HOMEOWNERS
ASSOCIATION TO DELIVER
SPECIFIED NOTICES BY THE
DELIVERY METHOD SPECIFIED BY
THE MEMBER AND TO CLARIFY THAT
A HOMEOWNER'S ASSOCIATION IS
ONLY REQUIRED TO POST PACIFIED
NOTICES ON ITS WEBSITE. IF IT
ALREADY HAS A WEBSITE SENATE
BILL THREE NINETY TWO WOULD
RECEIVE BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND
PASSED OFF THE SENATE FLOOR
WITH NO NO VOTES I RESPECTFULLY
ASK RIVAL. THANK YOU SENATOR
ARCH ALETTA MEMBERS ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SEEING
AND HEARING THAT MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN I ARCHULETA HI AT KINS I
BASE FIVE BECKER. FIVE FOR JESS
I BRADFORD HI BYRON. HI FOR
TESTING I DALLY. DODD I TORONTO
BY ADMIN. GLAZER FIVE DOLLARS I
GROSS OUR EFFORTS BERG I WAS SO.
HI HER TADO I JONES I CAN
LONGER. I LAYERED I LLEVA I THE
MON I REQUIRE I MELINDA'S BY
MEN. I NEWMAN I NIELSEN I A
SHOW OF BOTH. HI PAM I WOULDN'T
YOU KNOW I. ROSS. I RUBIO I
SKINNER. I STERN I AM BERG WHAT
KASKY FIVE WINNER I WILL. HI
PLEASE CALL THE OF THE MEMBERS.
DALLY BAGMAN. NUMBER ALL EYES
THIRTY CINEMAS CINEMAS A CALL.
OUR MEMBERS ARE MOVING ON TO
FILE ITEM TWENTY SIX SENATOR
DODD. BEN SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL THIRTEEN BY SENATOR
DODD AN ACT RELATING TO LOCAL
AGENCY FORMATION AND DECLARING
THE URGENCY BARRACKS EXPECT
IMMEDIATELY- MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS SP FIVE FIVE SIX WOULD
BRING CALIFORNIA CONFORMANCE
WITH FEDERALLY. EXISTED
EXISTING FEDERAL AND STATE LAW.
SEEKING TO ACCELERATE THE
DEPLOYMENT OF WIRELESS
BROADBAND NETWORK
INFRASTRUCTURE THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL. SENATOR DODD WE HAD
FALLEN TWENTY SIXES S. B.
THIRTEEN. WELL AT IT DID I
WOULD BE CORRECT THAT A
PRESIDENT OKAY VERY GOOD LET ME
GIVE MY APOLOGIES TO THE BODY
HAD A NUMBER OF DIFFERENT FILES
ON MY- BY THE US THAT IS OKAY
PLEASE PROCEED SENATOR DODD.
YES B. THIRTEEN BOOKS THEN THE
SUNSET OF A PILOT PROGRAM IN
NAPA AND SAN BERNARDINO
COUNTIES ALLOWING LAUGH GO
COMMISSIONS TO AUTHORIZE CITY
OR DISTRICT SERVICES OUTSIDE
URBAN BOUNDARIES RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR EYE BUT- THANK YOU
SENATOR DODD MEMBERS ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SEEING
AND HEARING THAT MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN HI ARCHULETA FIVE ATKINS
FIVE EIGHT I BACKER HI FOUR
JUST BY BRADFORD I COME BY ERA
HI CORTESE. HI DALLY. DODD I
TORONTO BY ADMIN. GLAZER ARE
YOU CONSOLIDATE FIVE GROSS.
FIVE HURTS BERG I WAS SO. I HER
TADO BY JONES I CAN LONGER. I
LAYERED I LLEVA I THE MON I
REQUIRE I MELINDA'S I MEN I
NEWMAN I NIELSEN I CHOSE BOTH.
I PAN I FORTUNE TINO HI ROTH. I
RUBIO I SKINNER BY STERN I AM
BERG. WHITE HOUSE SKI I WINNER
I WILL I. PLEASE PLEASE CALL
THE UPS MEMBERS. BALLY EGGMAN I
SUNDBERG WHY OKAY. FIVE THIRTY
EIGHT NINE ZERO THE ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN
MEMBERS WE'RE REMOVING TWO
SENATE THIRD READING FILE I'M
THIRTY ONE SENATOR BRADFORD MEN
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. SENATE
JOINT RESOLUTION SEVEN BY
SENATOR BRADFORD RELATIVE TO DR
MARTIN LUTHER KING JUNIOR AND
THE FBI SURVEILLANCE TAPES
SENATOR BRADFORD. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS I
STAND HERE TODAY. TO PRESENT.
ALI WON THE MOST IMPORTANT
DOCUMENTS AND DECLARATIONS.
DURING MY LEGISLATIVE CAREER
AND I RISE TODAY TO PRESENT AS
J. R. SEVEN. WHICH SIMPLY CALLS
FOR THE DESTRUCTION OF
RECORDINGS AND TRANSCRIPTS OF
DOCTOR MARTIN LUTHER KING
JUNIOR I WAS COLLECTED BY THE
FBI ALL THE WAY UP UNTIL HIS
DEATH. ADDITIONALLY THIS
RESOLUTION URGES THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT TO PREVENT SIMILAR
ABUSES OF POWER JUST FOR MORAL
AND THE FLOOR MAJORITY REASONS
THAT'S THE ONLY REASON FBI.
WIRETAPPED DR MARTIN LUTHER
KING TODAY DR KING IS BY ONE
THE MOST REVERED LEADERS THIS
COUNTRY HAS EVER KNOWN AND
POSSIBLY THE WORLD HIS NAME IS
SYNONYMOUS WITH EQUITY EQUALITY
JUSTICE. PEACE HIS LIVE LONGER
CONFIDENCE IN LEGACIES ARE
CELEBRATED THROUGHOUT THIS
COUNTRY. EVERY YEAR ON HIS
BIRTHDAY AND SOME PLACES AROUND
THE WORLD. HOWEVER DR KING WHEN
HE WAS ALIVE HE WAS VANDALIZED
REALLY NICE I SHOULD SAY AND
SLANDERED. BY MANY WHO OPPOSE
HIS MISSION OF EQUALITY OF
PEACE OF ENDING THE VIETNAM WAR
AND THEN INCLUDED OUR FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT. DR KING WAS A NOBEL
PRIZE WINNER YET J. EDGAR
HOOVER THE DIRECTOR OF THE F.
B. I.'S DECLARED DR KING THE
MOST DANGEROUS MAN IN AMERICA.
ALL CRAZY DIRECTOR HOOVER WAS
AGGRESSIVELY HOSTILE TOWARD DR
KING IN PARTICULAR ORDER IN HIS
AGENTS TO ENGAGE AND CONVERT
COVERT OPERATIONS AGAINST HIM.
OPERATIONS LIKE COUNTER INTEL
PAROLE WHICH WAS CREATED TO
INVESTIGATE BLACK NATIONALIST
HATE GROUPS ORGANIZATIONS LIKE
SCLC THE BLACK PANTHERS AND
DOUBLE ACP AND OTHER CIVIL
RIGHTS ORGANIZATIONS I GUESS IT
FOR WAS A LOT OF THE DAY OF THE
FOLLOWING BLACK LIVES MATTER
AND MAN. AND SEVERAL
ORGANISATIONS ARC YOU NAME IT
HE REPRISE ALBUM WIRE TAPPING
FOLLOW BEST BE I BEGAN
MONITORING DR KING IN DECEMBER
OF NINETEEN FIFTY FIVE DURING
HIS INVOLVEMENT WITH THE
MONTGOMERY BOYS THE BUS BOYCOTT.
SUPPOSEDLY BUT THEY WERE WRONG
BECAUSE OF HIS CONNECTIONS WITH
THE COMMUNIST PARTY. AND THEY
HELD HIM UNDER SURVEILLANCE FOR
THE LAST THIRTEEN YEARS OF HIS
LIFE. UNDER THE DRIVE P. I.
DOMESTIC COUNTERINTELLIGENCE
PROGRAM DR KING HIS FAMILY HIS
ASSOCIATES ALL WERE SUBJECTED
TO VARIOUS CRIMES OF FBI
SURVEILLANCE. THE FBI EVEN SENT
A NOTE. URGING DR MARTIN LUTHER
KING TO KILL HIMSELF TO AVOID
THE HUMILIATION OF THESE TAPES
BECOMING PUBLIC NOTICE AND
RECORD. VIDEO RECORDINGS AND
TRANSCRIPTS THIS CONTINUES TO
HAPPEN TODAY TO MANY BLACK
ACTIVISTS MOVEMENT OR FIGHTING
TO MAKE OUR COUNTRY A FAIRER
AND BETTER PLACE FOR ALL. FBI
LAW ENFORCEMENT AND LOCAL
POLICE FORCES HOW DO YOU SEE
SURVEILLANCE TACTICS TO TARGET
BLACK PEOPLE AND OTHER GROUPS
FIGHTING FOR RACIAL JUSTICE FOR
DECADES THEY EVEN CONTINUE
TODAY. ON HIS RESUME WE SAW IT
LAST YEAR WITH THE GEORGE FLOYD
MURDERS. FOR EXAMPLE BLACK
ACTIVISTS IN SAN FRANCISCO IT
TO SUIT CITY AND COUNTY OF SAN
FRANCISCO LAST YEAR BECAUSE OF
ALL LAWFUL SURVEILLANCE TACTICS.
CRAPPIE ARE RECORDED THE DR
MARTIN LUTHER KING ARE
SCHEDULED TO GO PUBLIC. FROM
OUR NATIONAL ARCHIVES IN TWENTY
TWENTY SEVEN. WHAT PURPOSE WHAT
DOES THE IDEA TO DR KING AND
OTHERS WAS UNLAWFUL IT WAS AN
INVASION OF PRIVACY AND IT'S
UNCONSTITUTIONAL TO SEARCH
UNDER THE FOURTH AMENDMENT OF
OUR CONSTITUTION DR KING WAS
AND IS A GREAT MAN. BUT HE WAS
NOT INVIOLABLE HE WAS A HUMAN
BEING LIKE THE REST OF US JUST
THINK FOR A MOMENT OUR MOST
PRIVATE MOMENTS WHEN OUR
FAMILIES OUR FRIENDS OR
COLLEAGUES. AND SOMEONE'S
EAVESDROPPING AND WIRE TAPPING
YOUR PHONE YOUR BEDROOM. THE
HOTEL ROOM YOUR CAR. NONE OF US
WOULD APPRECIATE THAT. ALTHOUGH
HE WAS AMONG OUR GREATEST
ORATORS IT WAS A DOLLY SPOKE.
AT EASE WITH HIS FRIENDS IN
COLLEGE LIKE MANY OF US DO ON A
DAILY BASIS. THE RECORDS OF
THESE PRIVATE MOMENTS WERE AN
OBSCENE AND ILLEGAL INTRUSION
INTO DR KING'S LIFE AND SHOULD
NOT NEVER. BE MADE PUBLIC. AND
NOT USE FOR STUFF LIKE A
SCANDAL. THIS IS WHY THIS
RESOLUTION NOT ONLY CALLS FOR
THESE UNLAWFUL TAPES TO BE
DESTROYED IT ALSO CALLS FOR THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO PREVENT
SIMILAR ABUSES. THIS RESOLUTION
FOCUSES ATTENTION ON THE
FAILURE OF OUR HISTORY THAT.
MUST BE CORRECTED LEAST WE
IGNORE IT PLUS WITH MORE NOR IT
I SHOULD SAY AND CONTINUE TO
PREFER PERPETRATE. THE SAME
INJUSTICE AGAINST OTHER CIVIL
RIGHTS ACTIVIST. DR KING'S
LEGACY DESERVES BETTER HIS
FAMILY DESERVES BETTER BUT MOST
IMPORTANTLY THIS NATION
DESERVES BETTER. WE CAN NO
LONGER BE SILENT REGARDING THIS
CRIMINAL ACT BY THE US
GOVERNMENT. DR KING SAYS THE
MOMENT WE REMAIN SILENT ON THE
MATTER IS THAT MATTER MOST OUR
LIVES BEGIN DAN I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR A VOTE. THANK YOU
SENATOR BRADFORD MEMBERS WILL
MOVE TO DISCUSSION AND DEBATE
SENATOR JONES. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT I RISE IN SUPPORT OF
S. J. R. SEVEN AS THE AUTHOR
HAS VERY ELOQUENTLY GIVEN THE
ARGUMENTS IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL. I ALSO SUPPORTED AS WELL-
JUST KIND OF LANDING ON THE
THOUGHT THAT THE U. S.
CONSTITUTION GIVES ALL OF US US
CITIZENS PROTECTION. FROM OUR
GOVERNMENT ILLEGALLY AND
INAPPROPRIATELY SURVEILLING US-
WITHOUT WARRANT OR WITHOUT
BECAUSE I BELIEVE THAT THE FBI
ACTED INAPPROPRIATELY. IN THESE
SITUATIONS AND- I SUPPORT IS J.
R. SEVEN AND ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS BECOME. THANK YOU SENATOR
JONES CENTER CALL LOGGER. THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I TO RISE
IN SUPPORT OF. S. J. R. SEVEN-
YOU KNOW THESE TAPES SHOULD BE
DESTROYED THEY SHOULD NOT BE
RELEASED- THEY CERTAINLY
DOCUMENT THE SURVEILLANCE AND
HARASSMENT OF DR KING- AND THE
IDEA BEHIND RELEASING THEM IS
REALLY TO SULLY THE NAME AND
LEGACY OF AN AMERICAN ICON. IF
YOU WERE GOING TO LOOK DEEPLY
INTO THE PAST I THINK IT WOULD
MAKE SENSE TO LOOK DEEPER. INTO
THE CHARACTER OF J. EDGAR
HOOVER WHO BELIEVE THAT HE WAS
ABOVE THE LAW. AND IN FACT-
THIS PART OF OUR HISTORY AS A
CAUTIONARY TALE FOR SO MANY.
ABOUT PRIVACY POWER AND AFFIX.
WE WOULD DO OURSELVES A
DISSERVICE TO GO BACK AND
EXAMINE THE PAST THAT WE CANNOT
CHANGE. WHY IS SOMEONE'S
PERSONAL LIFE OR THEIR
FRAILTIES OF ANY IMPORTANCE
WHAT DOES THIS ADD TO THE
DISCUSSIONS WE'RE HAVING ABOUT
OUR FUTURE THE RELEASE OF THESE
TAPES IS NOT ABOUT ART IT'S NOT
ABOUT CONTEXTUAL AS ASIAN. IT
IS REALLY JUST SALACIOUS AND
PERNICIOUS AND AN ATTEMPT TO
DENIGRATE SOMEONE WHO HAS DIED.
REALLY SO MANY OF US COULD
CONTINUE TO FIGHT FOR THE CIVIL
RIGHTS OF ALL AMERICANS. AND
THERE WOULD BE NO GREATER HARM
THAN TO RELEASE THESE TAPES I
ASK THAT YOU SUPPORT AND VOTE
I'D FOR AS J. R. SEVEN. THANK
YOU SENATOR CAMARGO CENTER
GROVE. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT I TO RAISE AND
SUPPORT OF ESTATE J. R. SEVEN
AND I THINK THE- MY COLLEAGUE
FROM GARDENA FOR- HIS ELOQUENT
REMARKS ABOUT- THE HISTORICAL
OF. LEGACY IN THE HISTORICAL
PRESENCE OF DR MARTIN LUTHER
KING. I ALSO THINK IT'S
APPALLING THAT THE FBI IN ANY
SITUATION WOULD BE ABLE TO
LISTEN TO AN AMERICAN- ANY
AMERICANS PERSONAL
CONVERSATIONS OBVIOUSLY WITHOUT
GOING THROUGH ANY PROPER
PROCESS. AND I THINK THE PROPER
PROCESS HAS BEEN DAMAGED SO
MUCH IN THE PAST THAT- IT WOULD
BE HARD TO. SAY THAT YOU COULD
ACTUALLY DO IT- TO ME IT
DOESN'T MATTER IF YOU'RE BLACK
WHITE IN JABI LATINO ASIAN. OR
ANY OTHER RACE THE UNITED
STATES GOVERNMENT SHOULD NOT BE
SPYING ON OR LISTENING TO
CONVERSATIONS- THAT TAKE PLACE
IN YOUR PERSONAL LIFE. AND LIKE
I SAID EARLIER IT'S APPALLING
THAT THE FBI WOULD HAVE DONE SO
TO MARTIN LUTHER KING. A JUNIOR
I DO- I DO THINK THAT AND THE
FOURTH AMENDMENT I DO KNOW THAT
THE FOURTH MEMO WAS PUT IN
PLACE TO PROTECT US AND EVERY
AMERICAN CITIZEN FROM.
SITUATIONS LIKE THIS AND- I
WOULD HOPE THAT REGARDLESS OF
WHO THAT UNITED STATES CITIZEN
IS- THAT IT WOULD NEVER HAPPEN
TO ANYONE. IN THIS IN THE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA ANYWAY
SO I SUPPORT THIS YEAR SEVEN I
THINK THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING
IT FORWARD AND I WOULD HOPE
THAT AND- THIS WOULD SEND A
CLEAR MESSAGE THAT THINGS LIKE
THIS SHOULD NOT BE TOLERATED.
IN THE UNITED STATES OF AMERICA
AGAINST HER CITIZENS THANK YOU
SIR FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD
AND I ASK FOR AN IPHONE. KEY
CENTER GROVE. PLEASE ENTER IN
THE SENATE IS THERE ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ANY DECENT
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. LAST CALL.
CENTRE BRADFORD WE LIKE TO
CLOSE. THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT I
WANT TO THANK MY COLLEAGUES WHO
STOOD UP AND WENT TO A VOICE TO
THIS VERY IMPORTANT MEASURE AS
STATED THERE IS NO EDUCATIONAL
OR CULTURAL BENEFIT OF THESE
TAPES THE SOLE PURPOSE OF THESE
TAPES FROM THE RECORDED DATA
AND FOR THEIR FUTURE POSSIBLE
RELEASES ONLY TO SULLY THE
REPUTATION OF A MAN WHO GAVE
HIS LIFE. LET ME SAY THIS AGAIN
WHO GAVE HIS LIFE FOR THIS
NATION AND IN MANY WAYS FOR
THIS WRLD FOR ALL OF US TO
LIVE AND- HM OUR WORLD IS FAR
FROM PERFECT BUT MUCH BETTER
THAN WHAT HE FOUND IT AND- THE
RELEASE. THE WORST CRIMINAL
ACTS YOU CAN DO TO A FAMILY TO
A MAN- TO THIS COUNTRY WE SHOW
HOW PETTY WE REALLY ARE AS A
COUNTRY IF WE DO THAT SO I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. ON
ENERGY ARE SELF CENTERED
REFEREES ASKING FOR AND I VOTE.
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
WITH ALAN HI I. ARCHULETA I AT
KINS BERNIE I BASE I BACKER. I
FOR JUST. BRADFORD I HAVE A
HYPERTENSIVE HI DALLY. DOT I-
ALSO I EXAMINE HI BLAZER HI
CONSOLIDATES FIVE GROWTH BY
HERTZ BURKE I WAS SO. HI TADO
BY JONES I CAN LONGER I LAYERED
HI LLEVA. LET ALONE I REQUIRE
HI MELINDA'S. MAN I NEWMAN I
NIELSEN I CHOSE BOTH I PAN. I
FIVE ROTH HI RUBIO I SKINNER I
STERN HI AMBERG. WHITE HOUSE
SKI I WINNER. I WILL I. HIGHS
THIRTY FIVE NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES LADIES AND GENTLEMEN THE
SENATE WE'RE NOW GOING TO BE
MOVING FORWARD TO ASSEMBLY
THIRD READING WE HAVE FOUR
MEASURES- IN FRONT OF US TODAY
ITEM IS. FIFTY SEVEN NINETY
NINE ONE TWELVE AND ONE THIRTY
FOUR WE'D LIKE TO BE A START
WITH FILE ITEM FIFTY SEVEN THAT
SENATOR UNTIL A BUG SENATOR YOU
PREPARE TO PRESENT SHE IS ONE
OF SECTOR CAN YOU PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL THREE FIFTY EIGHT
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER FLORA AN ACT
RELATING TO ELECTRIFIED
SECURITY FENCES. GOOD MORNING
SENATOR THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. MISTER
CHAIR EIGHTY THREE FIFTY EIGHT
WILL DEFINE WHAT MAKES UP A
MONITORED ELECTRIFIED FENCE
SYSTEM THESE SYSTEMS ARE
DESIGNED TO REINFORCE SECURITY
MONITORING BEHIND AN EXISTING
PERIMETER FENCE FOR BUSINESSES
SUCH AS FREIGHT CARRIERS
LOGISTIC WAREHOUSES DEALERSHIPS
COLLISION REPAIR SHOPS. OR
EQUIPMENT RENTAL SITES THEY'RE
NOT FOR RESIDENTIAL OR
AGRICULTURAL USE. THESE SYSTEMS
ARE SPECIFIC AND REMOVED FROM
THE PUBLIC THEY CAN ONLY BE
TRIGGERED IF TRESPASSING OCCURS
THIS CLARITY IN STATUE IS
NEEDED TO PROVIDE A CLEAR
FRAMEWORK OF WHAT THESE TYPES
OF SYSTEMS ARE SO THAT THE
PERMITTING CAN BE CONSISTENT
AND EFFICIENT. EIGHTY THREE
FIFTY EIGHT WILL HELP ENSURE
THAT BUSINESSES HAVE ALL THE
PROPER TOOLS AND THE OPTION TO
SECURE THEIR FACILITIES WITH
THIS TECHNOLOGY IN A TIMELY
MANNER. TO MAINTAIN PUBLIC
SAFETY AND PROBABLY DETER
TRESPASSING AND ASSOCIATED
IMPACTS OF THEFT. BURGLARY
VANDALISM AND ENDANGERMENT TO
EMPLOYEES THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SO MUCH SENATOR LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN THE SENATE WE'RE
GONNA BE GOING TO DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. THESE GUYS ARE GREAT
CENTER MY CASKEY WOULD YOU LIKE
TO SPEAK ON THIS ITEM. NOT ON
THIS ITEM THANK YOU SO UCH ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
FLOOR. THE FINAL CALL. XENON
BETTER SECTOR CAN YOU PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. THIS IS-
ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS CONSENT
IS THERE ANY OBJECTION. HEARING
C. NINE BIRDIES IN ASTRO CALL
ICE THIRTY EIGHT WHO KNOWS.
ZERO HIGHS THIRTY SEVEN NO ZERO
THE MEASURE PASSES LADIES AND
GENTLEMAN WE'RE NOT GONNA BE
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM NINETY
NINE. CENTER MY CASKET PREPARED
TO PRESENT. MENTOR SECTOR CAN
YOU PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL
SEVEN EIGHTY FOUR BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER QUIRK AN ACT
RELATED TO TRANSPORTATION GOOD
MORNING SIR MY CASKET THE FLOOR
IS YOURS I MISS PRESIDENT THIS
MEASURE MAKES TECHNICAL AND
CLARIFYING CHANGES TO THE
ALAMEDA CONTRA COSTA TRANSIT
DISTRICT LAWS WHICH WERE SET UP
IN NINETEEN FIFTY FOUR TO
REFLECT THE DISTRICT'S CURRENT
NEEDS MODERN TECHNOLOGY AND
JUDGMENTS ABOUT. OTHER STATE
CODE ADDITIONALLY DESIGNATES AC
TRANSIT AS A RAPID TRANSIT
DISTRICT SO THEY CAN MORE
QUICKLY I SEE THE SURGEON I
VOTE. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IS
THERE ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THE FLOOR. DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. HEARING C. NINE THIS
ITEM IS ELIGIBLE FOR YOU NAME
IS ROLL CALL IS THERE ANY
OBJECTION. HEARING SEE NO
OBJECTION FROM THE FLOOR HIGHS
THIRTY SEVEN NO ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN OF THE SENATE RIGHT
NOW COULD BE MOVING ON TO FILE
ITEM ONE TWELVE. BUT WE'RE
GOING TO BE LOOKING TOWARDS
SENATOR MINSITER MENTALLY
PREPARED TO PRESENT. IN A
MINUTE COMPARED 2% BETTER
CENTURY CAN YOU PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL FOURTEEN EIGHTY
BY SOME REMEMBER RODRIGUEZ AN
ACT RELATING TO PUBLIC
EMPLOYMENT THE MORNING CINNAMON
THE FLOOR IS YOURS THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT CURRENT LAW ALLOWS A
CRIMINAL JUSTICE AGENCY TO
COMPLETE A BACKGROUND CHECK ON
APPLICANTS FOR NON SWORN
POSITIONS. AND TO ASK AN
INDIVIDUAL ABOUT PRIOR ARRESTS.
HOWEVER DUE TO A LOOPHOLE IN
THE LAW ONCE AN APPLICANT IS
HIRED THE AGENCY CANNOT REQUEST
OR RECEIVE INFORMATION ABOUT
THAT NON SWORN EMPLOYEE ABOUT
ANY FUTURE S. EIGHTY FOURTEEN
EIGHTY WOULD PERMIT LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES TO REQUEST
AND RECEIVE A REST INFORMATION.
FOR SPECIFIC NON SWORN
EMPLOYEES I'M NOT MISTAKEN AND
SENATE PUBLIC SAFETY DE NIRO
THE ARRESTS OR DETENTIONS
SUBJECT TO THE DISCLOSURE THE
SERIOUS AND VIOLENT FELONIES AS
DEFINED AND CRIMES INVOLVING
DISHONESTY OR INSTRUCTION OF
LEGAL PROCESS THESE. ARE THIS
IS AN IMPORTANT MEASURE THAT
WOULD ALLOW LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES TO INVESTIGATE NON
SWORN EMPLOYEES AND HELP
SAFEGUARD THE INTEGRITY OF THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THANK
YOU SO MUCH LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN THE SENATE WOULD LIKE
TO SEE THERE'S DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THE FLOOR. LAST CALL
FOR DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
FLOOR. MEMBERS THIS ITEM IS
ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL IS THERE ANY OBJECTION.
SENIOR HEARING NO OBJECTION
HIGHS THIRTY SEVEN NO ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES. MEMBERS WE'RE
GOING TO BE MOVING ON TO OUR
LAST ITEM OF BUSINESS UNDER
ASSEMBLY THIRD READING THIS IS
FILE ITEM ONE THIRTY FOUR.
WHERE TO LOOK TO THE MAJORITY
LEADER IF HE'S PREPARED TO
PRESENT. THE MAJORITY LEADERS
PREPARED TO PRESENT. MADAM
SECRETARY CAN YOU PLEASE READ
ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHT OH THREE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MEMBER BURNER
**** BATH AN ACT RELATING TO
LAND USE GOOD MORNING MR
MAJORITY LEADER THE FLOOR IS
YOURS SIR THANK YOU VERY MUCH
PRESENT THIS MEASURE AUTHORIZES.
A THIRD A DEVELOPMENT
PROPONENTS STATEWIDE TO SUBMIT
APPLICATIONS FOR THE
CONSTRUCTION OF FEE SIMPLE
INFILL HOUSING ON SMALL LOTS.
IN MULTI FAMILY MIXED USE ZONES.
AS OF THIS MEASURE TO ATTRACT
NEW RESIDENTS CITIES MUST
PROVIDE NEW AFFORDABLE HOUSING
OPTIONS AMONG THE MANY BILLS
THAT WE'VE CONSIDERED. AS THE
CASE STUDY FOR THE LOS ANGELES
SMALL LOT ORDINANCE SHOWS SMALL
HOME LOT DEVELOPMENTS ARE
FEASIBLE UNITS. MEMBERS THAT
INCREASE HOMEOWNERSHIP
OPPORTUNITIES ALL WORKING
WITHIN EXISTING LAND USE
DESIGNS. THESE DEVELOPMENTS NOT
INCREASED ZONING DENSITY.
THEY'RE BUILT ON UNDER UTILIZED
LOTS IN MOST CASES. AND MOST
IMPORTANTLY SMALL LOT
DEVELOPMENTS ARE NOT SUBJECT TO
MONTHLY HOMEOWNERS ASSOCIATION
FEES. AS CONDOMINIUMS CHARGE
WHICH OFTEN CAN BE QUITE
EXTRAORDINARY US RIVAL. THANK
YOU SO MUCH AS THE MAJORITY
LEADER LADIES AND GENTLEMEN THE
SENATE DO WE HAVE ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
FLOOR. LAST CALL DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THE FLOOR. HEARING C.
NINE MEMBERS THIS ITEM IS
ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL DO WE HAVE ANY OBJECTION.
HEARING SEEN NO OBJECTION HIGHS
THIRTY SEVEN NO ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES. LADIES IN
GENERAL THE SENATE WE'RE GONNA
TAKE A QUICK PIES WILL BE RIGHT
BACK WITH YOU WE'RE GOING TO
REQUEST THAT THE- REPUBLICAN
LEADER PLEASE APPROACH THE DICE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
PATIENCE MEMBERS ALL RIGHT WE
WANT TO KEEP YOU ON YOUR TOES
THIS MORNING SO WE'RE GOING TO
ADD ONE MORE ITEM TO TODAY'S
BUSINESS TO KEEP IT FRESH WE'RE
GONNA BE MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM
THIRTY TWO. FILE I'M THIRTY TWO
HI THIS IS UNDER SENATE THIRD
READING CENTER FORTINOS
PREPARED TO PRESENT. MADAM
SECRETARY CAN YOU PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL SIX THIRTY ONE BY
SENATOR FORTUNE TINO AN ACT
RELATING TO STAKE CLAIMS MAKING
APPROPRIATIONS AIRPORTS AND
DECLARING THE URGENCY THERE OF
SIX IMMEDIATELY. GOOD MORNING
CENTER PRINTING OF THE FLOOR IS
YOURS THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT MEMBERS
AS B. SIX THREE ONE ASAN
URGENCY MEASURE TO APPROPRIATE
ONE POINT TWO MILLION DOLLARS
FROM THE GENERAL FUND. TO THE
VICTIMS COMPENSATION BOARD FOR
THE PAYMENT OF A RECENTLY
APPROVED STATE CLAIM RELATED TO
THE AROUND HIS CONVICTION AND
MR WILLIAM RICHARDS THE COURT
SET ASIDE HIS CONVICTION AND
MADE A FINDING OF FACTUAL
INNOCENCE AFTER HE'D ALREADY
SERVED OVER TWENTY TWO YEARS IN
PRISON. FOR A CRIME HE DID NOT
COMMIT THE BOARD APPROVE THE
CLAIM AND RECOMMENDS AN
APPROPRIATION TO COVER THE
PAYMENT REQUIRED BY THE STATUTE
SB SIX THIRTY ONE HAD UNANIMOUS
SUPPORT IN COMMITTEE. AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS. THANK YOU SO MUCH SOONER
TINO LADIE IN JENISON AND WE
WANT TO SEE IF THERE'S ANY
DISCUSSION OR DBATE ON THE
FLOOR. LAST CALL DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THE FLOOR. HEARING C.
NINE. COLLEAGUES THIS ITEM IS
ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL IS THERE ANY OBJECTION.
HEARING IN CHINO JUNCTION ON
THE URGENCY HIGHS THIRTY SEVEN
NO ZERO ON THE MEASURE HIGHS
THIRTY SEVEN NO ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES THANK YOU SO
MUCH. MEMBERS ARE NOW GOING TO
BE MOVING ON TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS WE'RE GONNA
RECOGNIZE SENATOR MELINDA IS
GOOD MORNING CENTER MINUS IT
THANK YOU SO MUCH GOOD MORNING
SAM REQUIRE LACING GENTLEMEN-
PURSUANT TO GENERAL TWENTY TO
MAKING A MOTION WITHDRAWAL AS
SIERRA FIVE FROM THE SENATE
GOVERNMENTAL ORGANIZATION
COMMITTEE BROUGHT TO THE SENATE
FLOOR SO WE CAN HAVE A FULL
INVADERS DEBATE. SOME FIVE
HUNDRED TWENTY FOUR DAYS SINCE
THE GOVERNOR DECLARED A STATE
OF EMERGENCY AND SHUT DOWN THE
STATE EVERYONE WANTS A
VACCINATION CAN NOW GET ONE IN
FACT 62% OF CALIFORNIANS HAVE
DONE SO. LA TIMES REPORTED THIS
WEEK THOSE INFECTED WITH KEVIN
NINETEEN AND FALLING SERIOUSLY
ILL IS NO LONGER AN
ACCELERATING AND IS EVEN
FLATTENING. THE- THE- THE WEEK
OVER WEEK NEW CASE RATE HAS
DECLINED 23% FROM LAST WEEK AND
HOSPITALIZATIONS ARE SLOWING-
GIVEN ALL OF THESE FACTS ARE
REMIND YOU IT IS BEEN FIVE
HUNDRED AND TWENTY FOUR DAYS I
THINK IT'S TIME. TO PUT THE
DECISION MAKING BACK WHERE IT
BELONGS PLEASE DON'T BE ARAID
TO TAKE A STAND ON THIS MEASURE
YOUR CONSTITUENTS WANT TO KNOW
WHERE YOU STAND AND I ASK FOR
YOUR I DON'T. THANK YOU SO MUCH
SOONER MELINDA CENTER MELINDA'S
IS ASKING FOR AND I VOTE GOOD
MORNING MR MAJORITY LEADER.
THANK YOU NOTE VERY MUCH IN THE
STAND A NO VOTE THE MAJORITY
RESTAURANT NOBLE. MAJORITY
LEADER IS ASKING FOR A NO VOTE
CENTER MELINDA'S IS ASKING FOR
AN IPHONE. MADAM SECRETARY CAN
YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN
NO R. ARCHULETA. NO AT KINS. NO
BASE. FIVE BACKER NO PORGES I
BRADFORD. I KNOW HOW BY ADAM NO
FOUR TIMES HE- NO DALLY DOT NO
TORONTO NO EGGMAN NO GLAZER NO
GUNS ALL THIS NO GROWTH. HI
HURTS BURKE NO WEST SO NO HER
TADO NO JONES I CAN LONGER NO
LAYERED. NO LLEVA THE MON. NO
MCGUIRE NO MELINDA'S FIVE MEN.
NO NEWMAN NO NIELSEN I A CHILL
OF BOTH I PAN. NO FORTUNE TINO.
NO ROTH NO RUBIO. NO SKINNER.
NO STERN NO AMBERG WHITE HOUSE
E. NO WINNER. NO WELL I HIGHS
EIGHT NOS TWENTY NINE THE
MOTION TO WITHDRAW SALES LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN OF THE SENATE
WE'RE NOW GOING TO BE MOVING
BACK. EXCUSING SAID ARCHULETA-
FOR WHAT PURPOSE YEAH. TO
REMOVE AN ITEM MISSING
RESIDENTS HERE AND I REQUESTED
A B. THIRTEEN FIFTY TWO WHICH
IS ITEM TWO THIRTY THREE CHILD
IS PULLED FROM THE CONSENT
FILE. AND I THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT THANK YOU SO MUCH
MISTER SENATOR MEMBERS IS ANY
OTHER ITEMS THAT MEMBERS ARE
GOING TO NEED TO BE- WOULD DROP
THIS TIME. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
MEMBERS ARE GONNA CONTINUE WITH
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS AND
THIS IS THEIR TIME TO ADDRESS
THE BODY WITH. ADJOURNS IN
MEMORY WE HAVE A FEW THAT ARE
GOING TO BE ADVANCED HERE THIS
MORNING. BUT WE LIKE TO BE ABLE
TO WELCOME SENATOR CAFIERO
SENATOR KABIR. I SENT A COUPLE
HERE- WITH INSURANCE IN MEMORY.
IT WAS JUST A FEW MOMENTS WILL
BE RIGHT BACK WITH YOU IN
GENERAL. ALL RIGHT SIR HAVE A
HERO GOOD AT A GOOD MORNING THE
FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT. MEMBERS ARRIVED
TODAY VIA TO ASK THE SENATE TO
ADJOURN IN THE MEMORY MEMORY OF
THE HONORABLE HENRY PULLEY THE
CELERIO. MR SOLORIO WAS A
BELOVED COMMUNITY LEADERS AND
ELECTED OFFICIAL THAT LEAVES
BEHIND A LEGACY OF HARD WORK.
DEDICATION SACRIFICE FAMILY AND
OF COURSE. HIS SENSE OF HUMOR
HE WAS BORN AND RAISED IN THE
MORE A SMALL. CITY IN RURAL
CALIFORNIA AND WHEN HE WAS JUST
THREE. HE TRAGICALLY LOST HIS
MOTHER DESPITE THIS LOSS HENRY
AND HIS FATHER ENDURED AND
HENRY WOULD EVENTUALLY JOINED
HIS FATHER TRAVELING UP AND
DOWN THE STATE FOR SIS ON
SEASONAL AGRICULTURAL WORK. AS
A TEAM. HENRY MOVED TO
HOLLISTER AND VOLUNTEERED TO
JOIN THE US ARMY AND WAS
STATIONED AT LACKLAND ARMY AIR
FORCE BASE IN SAN ANTONIO
TEXAS. TRAVELING TO AND FROM
THE BASE BY TRAIN. DURING HIS
SERVICE HENRY PICKED UP BOXING
AND PARTICIPATED IN THE GOLDEN
GLOVES COMPETITION FOR SEVERAL
YEARS AFTER HIS HONORABLE
DISCHARGE AND RETURNED TO
HOLLISTER. UPON HIS RETURN
HENRY MET AND LATER MARRIED HIS
WIFE GENIE CODA THEY CELEBRATED
SIXTY EIGHT YEARS OF MARRIAGE
UNTIL HER PASSING IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN. IN NINETEEN FIFTY
HENRY STARTED WORKING FOR TRI
VALLEY GROWERS IN HOLLISTER
AFTER HIS DISCHARGE AND WORKED
HIS WAY UP TO WAREHOUSE
MANAGER. WHEN HE WHERE HE
RETIRED IN THEMID NINETEEN
NINETIES HENRY SOLORIO WAS
COMMITTED TO COMMUNITY
EMPOWERMENT AND WAS A
TRAILBLAZER IN THE LATE
EIGHTEEN SIXTY HE EARNED AN
APPOINTMENT TO THE HOLLISTER
CITY PLANNING COMMISSION WASN'T
EVENTUALLY ELECTED TO THE
HOLLISTER CITY COUNCIL WHERE HE
SERVED AS MAYOR. HENRY SALUTE
HERE WAS A STAUNCH ALLY OF THE
FARMWORKER COMMUNITY AND WAS
AMONG THE FIRST MARES IN
CALIFORNIA TO ENDORSE THE
BOYCOTT BY THE UNITED FARM
WORKERS HE WAS ALSO THE FIRST
MEXICAN AMERICAN TO SERVE ON
THE SAN BENITO COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS. WHERE HE SERVED
FOR FOUR YEARS. BELIEVING THAT
EDUCATION IS THE FOUNDATION OF
PROGRESS FOR THE ECONOMIC
ADVANCEMENT OF THE LATINO
COMMUNITY HENRY SALUTE YOUR
BECAME A FOUNDING MEMBER OF
MACE THE MEXICAN AMERICAN
COMMITTEE ON EDUCATION. A
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION WHICH
RAISED MONEY FOR COLLEGE
SCHOLARSHIPS FOR HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENTS AND ANECDOTALLY THEY
HAVE RAISED HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS OVER THE
YEARS AND HAVE. BASICALLY PUT
STUDENTS FROM HOLLISTER SAN
BENITO COUNTY THROUGH COLLEGE
AND MANY OF THEM HAVE RETURNED
AS PROFESSIONALS IN THE
COMMUNITY. WHO IS ALSO THE
CHAIRMAN OF THE SAN BENITO
JOINT UNION HIGH SCHOOL
CITIZENS PARENT ADVISOR
COMMITTEE I'M BILINGUAL
BICULTURAL PROGRAMS. DURING HIS
POLITICAL CAREER AND THROUGHOUT
HIS LIFE HAD RESELLER WITH A
CHAMPION PERFECT HIS
CONSTITUENTS AND INTER ENSURED
THAT THEIR VOICES WERE NOT ONLY
HEARD BUT THAT MEANINGFUL
CHANGE CAME ABOUT TO ADDRESS
THEIR NEEDS HE BELIEVED
REPRESENTATION IN POLITICS IS
IMPORTANT. AND WITH AN ACTIVE
SUPPORTER OF LOCAL WOMEN
CANDIDATES AND ELECTED
OFFICIALS AND THAT'S HOW I MET
HIM AND THROUGH HIS WORK AND
MACE IN HIS SPARE TIME HE
VOLUNTEERED REGULARLY WITH LOWS
AND FISHES TO PROVIDE FOOD. AND
SUPPORT TO THE COMMUNITY
ESPECIALLY IMMIGRANT
FARMWORKERS. HENRY SELLER WAS A
HUMP AND KIND MAN WHO NEVER HAD
A BAD WORD FOR ANYONE HE WAS
ALWAYS THERE FOR PEOPLE WHO HAD
FALLEN ON TOUGH TIMES AND
FILLED ANY ROOM WITH THIS
WARMTH AND LAUGHTER. HE WAS A
GENTLEMAN AND A TRUE SERVANT
AND HIS PERSEVERANCE AND
DEDICATION TO HIS COMMUNITY
WILL INSPIRE FUTURE GENERATIONS
OF CALIFORNIANS. AND SAN BENITO
COUNTY RESIDENTS HE IS SURVIVED
BY HIS FIVE CHILDREN SIX
GRANDCHILDREN AND HIS SISTER.
THANK YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST THAT THE SENATE
ADJOURNED IN HE MEMORY OF THE
HONORABLE HENRY SELLER SELLER
TO GO. IN A CAREER THANK YOU
FOR DANCING THE JOURNEY MARINE
POLICING THE DEEPEST REGRETS TO
HIS FAMILY THANK YOU SO MUCH.
MEMBERS WOULD LIKE TO BE ABLE
TO MOVE FORWARD WITH OUR NEXT
ATTORNEY MARIE. BUT FIRST CAN
HEAR FROM SENATOR WIENER. THEN
THIS FROM SENATOR LAYERED. SIR
WE ARE THE FLOOR IS YOURS GOOD
MORNING. I THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT- I RISE TO ASK THAT
SHE SENT A JOURNEY IN MEMORY OF
AMBASSADOR JAMES HORMEL. WHO IS
ONE OF OUR GREAT
PHILANTHROPISTS DIPLOMATS AND
OUR NATION'S FIRST OPENLY LGBT
Q. AMBASSADOR HI JIM PASSED
AWAY ON AUGUST THIRTEENTH. AT
THE AGE OF EIGHTY EIGHT YEARS
OLD HE WAS TRULY ONE OF OUR%
GREAT MODERN LGBTQ COMMUNITY
LEADERS IN THIS NATION BORN IN
NINETEEN THIRTY THREE AND
AUSTIN MINNESOTA- THE GRANDSON
OF- FORMEL FOODS FOUNDER GEORGE
A. HORMEL HI JIM IT'S ATTENDED
SWARTHMORE COLLEGE WHERE HE
EARNED A BACHELOR'S DEGREE IN
HISTORY. HE WENT THERE AFTER A
LAW DEGREE FROM UNIVERSITY OF
CHICAGO SCHOOL OF LAW AND
SERVED AS A TEEN- CHICAGO LAW
SCHOOL- IN NINETEEN NINETY FIVE
AND NINETY SEVEN- JIM SERVED IN
THE WESTERN STATES REGIONAL
SELECTION PANEL FOR THE
PRESIDENT'S COMMISSION ON WHITE
HOUSE FELLOWSHIPS. I ALSO ACTED
AS AN ALTERNATE REPRESENTATIVE
FOR THE U. S. DELEGATION TO THE
FIFTY FIRST UNITED NATIONS
GENERAL ASSEMBLY IN NINETEEN
NINETY SIX AND HE SERVED AS THE
UNITED STATES AMBASSADOR TO
LUXEMBOURG- IN NINETEEN NINETY
NINE AND TWO THOUSAND. HI JIM
IS ONE OF SAN FRANCISCO'S AND
LGBTQ COMMUNITY'S FOREMOST
LEADERS AND PHILANTHROPISTS-
I'M HAVING FUN SO MANY CRITICAL
COMMUNITY LEADS THE NEEDS
INCLUDING FOR EXAMPLE- THE
JAMES HORMEL LGBTQ I A CENTER-
AT THE SAN FRANCISCO PUBLIC
LIBRARY- THE AIDS MEMORIAL
GROVE IN GOLDEN GATE PARK IN
SAN FRANCISCO. THE HUMAN RIGHTS
CAMPAIGN AND SO MANY OTHER
COMMUNITY ORGANIZATIONS HE WAS
A CO FOUNDER OF THE HUMAN
RIGHTS CAMPAIGN FORTY YEARS AGO
WHICH IS THE LARGEST LGBTQ
CIVIL. RIGHTS ORGANIZATION IN
THE COUNTRY. I JIM WAS ALSO- A
HUGE PROPONENT OF THE ART- WITH
THE FINANCIAL SUPPORTER OF THE
AMERICAN CONSERVATORY THEATER.
ABOVE ALL ELSE HE WAS A GREAT
FRIEND FATHER MY GRANDFATHER
AND GREAT GRANDFATHER WHO
DEDICATED HIS LIFE IN SERVICE
TO OTHERS. NORMALLY IN THESE
INSURANCE THE MEMORIES WE WANT
TO FOCUS ONLY ON THE POSITIVE
BUT THERE WAS A SIGNIFICANT
HAPPENING IN THE LATE NINETIES
AROUND JIM'S LIFE BUT I THINK
IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT TO
REMEMBER. AND I THINK JIM WOULD
WANT US TO REMEMBER AND THAT IS
WHEN PRESIDENT BILL CLINTON
NOMINATED JAM TO BE AMBASSADOR
TO LUXEMBOURG. THERE WERE NO
QUESTIONS WHATSOEVER ABOUT
JIM'S EXTREME QUALIFICATIONS TO
REPRESENT OUR COUNTRY- IN
LUXEMBOURG- BUT UNFORTUNATELY
HIS NOMINATION HIS
CONFIRMATION- WAS DERAILED IN
THE SENATE- BY RIGHT WING
SENATORS. OUT OF PURE
UNADULTERATED ON MASS FROM A
PHOBIA AND THIS IS IN THE LATE
NINETEEN NINETIES AND IT'S A
REMINDER- THAT IT WASN'T THAT
LONG AGO- THIS WAS CONSIDERED
ACCEPTABLE. ACTIVITY AND
DISCOURSE- AT LEAST IN ONE OF
THE MAJOR NATIONAL PARTIES. BY
THE SENATE DID NOT CONFIRM HIM
AND WE HEARD STATEMENTS FROM
THE UNITED STATES SENATORS- IN
THE LATE NINETEEN NINETIES
OPPOSING HIM FOR. SUPPORTING
THE QUOTE UNQUOTE GAY AGENDA-
ONE SENATOR SAID. QUOTE THIS IS
NOT A TOLERANCE ISSUE THIS IS A
MATTER OF ADVOCACY OF THE GAY
LIFESTYLE. THE MAJORITY LEADER
SENATOR TRENT LOTT- WENT ON TV
AND SAID QUOTE. YOU SHOULD TRY
TO SHOW THEM REFERRING TO LGBT
PEOPLE A WAY TO DEAL WITH THAT
PROBLEM JUST LIKE ALCOHOL OR
SEX ADDITION OR CLICK THE
MANIACS- HE ALSO. ISSUED A
STATEMENT QUOTE SENATOR LOTT
OPPOSES THE NAMING OF SOMEONE.
WHO HAS SUPPORTED AN EXTREMIST
ANTI CATHOLIC GROUP TO
REPRESENT THE U. S. REFERRING
TO THE SISTERS OF PERPETUAL.
INDULGENCE ONE OF THE MOST
BELOVED COMMUNITY ORGANIZATIONS
IN SAN FRANCISCO WHICH RAISES
ENORMOUS AMOUNTS OF MONEY TO
SUPPORT OUR MOST MARGINALIZED
COMMUNITIES- THE FAMILY
RESEARCH COUNCIL AND
TRADITIONAL VALUES COALITION.
OPPOSE THE NOMINATION. BASED ON.
GEMS DONATION OF FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS TO THE SAN
FRANCISCO PUBLIC LIBRARY TO
CREATE AN LGBTQ. ARCHIVE ON ON
ON THIS HORRIFIC STATEMENTS
OPPOSING HIS NOMINATION
FORTUNATELY- HE WAS- PRESIDENT
CLINTON PERSISTED I WAS ABLE TO
NAME HIM AS A RECESS
APPOINTMENT AND HE SERVED
HONORABLY FOR TWO YEARS AND
THEN SPENT THE NEXT TWENTY
YEARS CONTINUING. HIS
INCREDIBLE SERVICE ATTIRE OUR
COMMUNITY. I'M JIM PASSED AWAY
IN SAN FRANCISCO AS I MENTIONED
AUGUST THIRTEENTH OF NATURAL
CAUSES. HE'S SURVIVED BY HIS
HUSBAND MICHAEL- BY HIS
CHILDREN ALLISON ANALISA BIT
JIMMY AND SARAH- BY HIS
FOURTEEN GRANDCHILDREN AND BY
HIS SEVEN GREAT GRANDCHILDREN-
I WILL ALSO- TO SAY THAT I I'VE
KNOWN JOHN YOU JIM PERSONALLY-
THIS SINCE I MOVED TO SAN
FRANCISCO IN THE IN THE MID
NINETEEN NINETIES. HE WAS TRULY
ONE OF THE MOST WONDERFUL HUMAN
BEINGS THAT I'VE KNOWN TO START
A PLEASANT UP BE LOVELY PERSON
WHO JUST CARE DEEPLY ABOUT
SUPPORTING THE COMMUNITY AND
NEVER ASKED FOR ANYTHING- IN
RETURN JUST WANTED TO BE THERE
FOR HIS COMMUNITY AND FOR OUR
GREAT CITY OF SAN FRANCISCO.
YOUR COLLEAGUES I ASKED AT THE
SENATE ADJOURNED. IN MEMORY OF
AMBASSADOR JAMES HORMEL THANK
YOU SO MUCH SENATOR WIENER ON
NATURE IN THE MEMORY OF THE
AMBASSADOR THE SENATE WOULD
LIKE TO RECOGNIZE CENTER
EARLIER GOOD MORNING THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MR PRESIDENT. OF
SENATOR WINNER DID A GREAT JOB
OF OUTLINING OF THE BIOGRAPHY
OF JIM HORMEL AND WHO HE WAS
AND IS SCOTT PHILANTHROPIC AND
CIVIC CONTRIBUTIONS. N. AS
SOMEBODY THAT KNEW HIM IN THAT
PERIOD. R. HE DID HAVE THOSE
CHARACTERISTICS OF HE WAS QUIET
WARMTH DIGNITY. A AND I THINK
INTERESTINGLY THOSE WERE
PROBABLY THE PERFECT
CHARACTERISTICS FOR SOMEBODY.
THAT WAS A TRAILBLAZER. I AS
SOMEBODY THAT KNEW HOW. IT WAS
HARD. TO WATCH WHAT HAPPENED
BECAUSE THE SPECIFIC PART OF IT
WAS. IS HE WAS APPOINTED. AND
IT COULD NOT GET THROUGH THE
SENATE AND PRESIDENT CLINTON
HAD TO DO A RECESS APPOINTMENT.
TO MAKE IT HAPPEN AND THE
INTERESTING THING WAS IS THERE
WAS A DEBATE. WHICH SEEMS. SO
PREHISTORIC NOW. ABOUT WHETHER
HIS SPOUSE COULD COME WITH HIM
TO THE COUNTRY OR COULD APPEAR
AT OFFICIAL EVENTS FOR QUICK
EVEN LIVE OR BE SEEN IN THE
AMBASSADOR'S RESIDENCE THAT
HAPPENED JUST ROUGHLY A QUARTER
CENTURY AGO. AND YET. IT WAS
HIS PERSONAL CHARACTERISTICS
THAT FOR THE RESPONSE WHERE
WHICH IS THE REASON THAT THEY
WERE PROBABLY PERFECT FOR
SOMEBODY TO BE SUCH A
TRAILBLAZER. SO I THINK HE WILL
GO DOWN IN HISTORY AND TO THE
COMMUNITY TO HIS FRIENDS TO
FAMILY- IT IS A BIG LOSS SO-
ARE JOINED. IN THE GERMAN
MEMORY TO SOMEBODY THAT WAS A
GREAT STATE. THINNER LAYER
JOINING WITH SENATOR WIENER ON
BEHALF OF THE JOURNEY MEMORY OF
AMBASSADOR JAMES HORMEL THANK
YOU GENTLEMEN. WE HAVE ONE
FINAL JOURNEY MEMORY TODAY WE
LIKE TO START WITH SINNERS RISE
SO- IN MEMORY OF MR TRUMKA WILL
THEN HEAR FROM THE PRESIDENT
PRO TEM SACKINGS. INDIAN FROM
MISTER CORTESE. CENTER DRIVE SO
THE FLOOR IS YOURS GREAT. THANK
YOU MR PRESIDENT. THIS MORNING
I REQUEST THAT WE ADJOURN IN
MEMORY OF RICHARD TRUMKA THE
LONGTIME LEADER AND PRESIDENT
OF THE AFL-CIO. THAT'S THE WAY
UNEXPECTEDLY ON AUGUST FIFTH.
AFL-CIO IS MADE UP OF FIFTY SIX
NATIONAL AND INTERNATIONAL
UNIONS REPRESENTING TWELVE AND
A HALF MILLION WORKING MEN AND
WOMEN. RICHARD TRUMKA WAS A
THIRD GENERATION COAL MINER
FROM IMMIGRANT ITALIAN AND
POLISH STOCK. GROWING UP IN THE
LITTLE APPALACHIAN COAL TOWN OF
MAMMOTH COLIN IN SOUTHWEST
PENNSYLVANIA. HE WAS ELECTED
PRESIDENT OF HIS UNION THE
UNITED MINE WORKERS OF AMERICA
ARGUABLY THE SINGLE MOST
IMPORTANT UNION IN AMERICAN
LABOR HISTORY. THAT UNION WAS
THE DRIVING FORCE IN THE
CREATION OF THE MASSIVE
INDUSTRIAL LABOR ORGANIZING
CAMPAIGNS OF THE GREAT
DEPRESSION. IN NINETEEN EIGHTY
NINE FOR THE TRUMP GOT LEAD. AN
EPIC TEN MONTHS STRIKE OF TWO
THOUSAND UNION MINERS AGAINST
THE PITTSTON COAL COMPANY. I
HAD JUST BEEN ELECTED PRESIDENT
OF MY LOCAL UNION AND THE
PITTSTON STRIKE WAS A NATIONAL
INSPIRATION FOR US IT WAS MY
FIRST EXPERIENCE IN SUPPORT OF
WORKERS ON STRIKE ON A NATIONAL
INTERNATIONAL CAMPAIGN. I AM
ESPECIALLY PROUD BECAUSE OUR
UNION EIGHT CHERRY ST FIVE
COOKS TO CAMP SOLIDARITY TO
PREPARE THREE MEALS A DAY SEVEN
DAYS A WEEK UNTIL THE STRIKERS
ONE. NINETEEN NINETY FIVE FOR
THE TRUMP KERR JOINED JOHN
SWEENEY AND LINDA CHAVEZ
THOMPSON IN THE FIRST CONTESTED
ELECTION IN THE AFL CIO'S.
HISTORY AS A FEDERATION THE
ONE. ELECTED THE FIRST WOMAN
AND PERSON OF COLOR AS A
NATIONAL OFFICER ON HIS SLATE.
WHICH TRUMP KERR WAS COMMITTED
TO ORGANIZE A NEW LABOR
MOVEMENT. AS A SIGNAL TO HIS
THAT COMMITMENT HE DECIDED TO
HOLD THE NEXT AFL-CIO
CONVENTION IN LOS ANGELES IN
NINETEEN NINETY NINE. ON THE
SECOND DAY OF THE CONVENTION
BROTHER TRUMKA I HAD THE
PRIVILEGE. OF MARCHING WITH
BROTHER BROTHER TRUMKA AS HE
LED THOUSANDS OF CONVENTION
DELEGATES TO THE STREETS OF
DOWNTOWN LOS ANGELES. IN THE
FIRST EVER NATIONAL LABOR
MOVEMENT MARCH IN SUPPORT OF
IMMIGRANT WORKERS. THIS IS THAT
THE NEW YORK COUNTY HOTEL WHICH
WE WERE ORGANIZING HUNDREDS OF
WORKERS OF EVENTUALLY WON
UNIONIZATION. AT THIS
CONVENTION THERE FOR L. C. I.
U. BROKE WITH ITS PAST. AND
APPROVE THE HISTORIC STANDUP
FOR IMMIGRANT WORKERS
RESOLUTION ACKNOWLEDGING THE
ROLE OF UNIONS TO DEFEND
UNDOCUMENTED WORKERS AS
BROTHERS AND SISTERS IN THE
SAME LABOR MOVEMENT. I AM
PRIVILEGED TO HAVE CHAIRED THE
NATIONAL F. L. C. I. U.
IMMIGRATION COMMITTEE AND TO
HAVE SERVED ON THE AFL-CIO
EXECUTIVE COUNCIL. THE HIGHEST
BODY IN THE INFO ABOUT SEO
UNDER BROTHER TRUMP IS
LEADERSHIP HE WAS BOLD AND HE
WAS UNWAVERING IN HIS
COMMITMENT TO ALL WORKING
FAMILIES. THE PRO WORKER PRO
IMMIGRANT DOCTRINE OF HIS
CATHOLIC FAITH INFORMED HIS
SENSE OF SOLIDARITY. HE SAW AND
FELT THE COMMON GROUND BETWEEN
THE LABOR MOVEMENT AND THE
IMMIGRANTS RIGHTS MOVEMENT HE
SAW AND FELT THE COMMON GROUND
BETWEEN MINERS IN PENNSYLVANIA
AND MINERS IN SOUTH AFRICA
FIGHTING TO DISMANTLE
APARTHEID. HE SAW THE COMMON
GROUND BETWEEN WHITE STEEL
WORKERS IN OHIO AN AFRICAN
AMERICAN RUNNING FOR PRESIDENT
OF THE U. S. HE SAW THE COMMON
GROUND BETWEEN. SOUTH ASIAN
TAXI DRIVERS AND LET THE IN THE
DOMESTIC WORKERS. ALONGSIDE
PAINTERS UNLIKE TRADITIONS. HE
SAW THE COMMON GROUND BETWEEN
THE SIX YEAR STRIKE OF LAS
VEGAS FRONTIER CASINO WORKERS
AND THE PITS AND STRIKERS. ON A
PERSONAL NOTE. ON THE OCCASION
OF THE TWENTY THIRTEEN AFL-CIO
CONVENTION IN LOS ANGELES HE
AGREED TO DO THE TRADITIONAL
EVENING AT A BASEBALL GAME. HE
WAS A HARDCORE PIRATES FAN BUT
HE SWALLOWED HIS DISLIKE FOR
THE DODGERS AND THREW OUT THE
FIRST PITCH I GOT TO CATCH IT.
HE WAS A DEVOTED HUSBAND FATHER
AND GRANDFATHER HE LEFT LEFT US
FAR TOO SOON. OUR LABOR
MOVEMENT AND MILLIONS OF
WORKERS HERE AND ALL OVER THE
WORLD MOURN HIS DEATH. THOSE
SAME WORKERS WILL RECOMMIT TO
THE IDEALS OF JUSTICE THE
BROTHER RICH TRUMKA DEDICATED
HIS LIFE. COLLEAGUES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK WITH GERMAN IN
HIS NAME. SENATOR AWESOME THANK
YOU THAT WAS BEAUTIFUL WE'RE
NOT GONNA RECOGNIZE PRESIDENT
PRO TEM MACHEN'S ON THE JOURNEY
MEMORY OF RICHARD TRUMKA MADAM
PRESIDENT THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT AND- I AM CLEARLY NOT
GOING TO HAVE THE ARTICULATE
COMMENTS FROM MY THAT MY
COLLEAGUE FROM LOSANGELES JUST
MADE. BUT I REALLY HAD TO GET
UP AND SAY A FEW THINGS FROM A
VERY PERSONAL PERSPECTIVE. YOU
KNOW- I NEVER THOUGHT I'D HEAR
THE WORD PITTSTON COAL COMPANY
OR COAL MINERS ACTUALLY ON THE
FLOOR OF THE SENATE AND I'M
REALLY SORRY THAT WE'RE HEARING
IT TODAY IN CONJUNCTION WITH
THE PASSING OF- A VERY DECENT
MAN. A VERY- INCREDIBLE
ADVOCATE FOR WORKING PEOPLE AND
TO THE COMMENTS- THAT MY
COLLEAGUE FROM LOS ANGELES MADE.
YOU KNOW- I GREW UP MY DAD WAS
A LEAD MINER COAL MINER. AND SO
I'M USED TO PEOPLE NOT
UNDERSTANDING THE FIGHT OF SOME
OF THOSE WORKERS. AND
DISMISSING WHOLE COMMUNITIES OF
PEOPLE BECAUSE OF THE TYPE OF
WORK THEY DO THAT MIGHT NOT BE
THE BEST. A FROM AN
ENVIRONMENTAL STANDPOINT BUT-
SHE CALLED SHE SHE MY COLLEAGUE
SAID HE WAS HARD CORE HE
ABSOLUTELY WAS HARD CORE- IN
THE WAYS THAT HE PRESENTED HIS
MESSAGE. WHEN I FINALLY MET-
RICHARD TRUMKA FOR ME IT WAS
LIKE MEETING CELEBRITIES ONLY
SECOND TO MY FAVORITE PERSON OF
ALL TIME DOLLY PARTON. SO THAT
INSPIRES AND TELLS YOU HOW
IMPORTANT- THE WORK THAT HE DID
WAS FOR ME AND MY FAMILY-
PARTICULARLY- YOU KNOW SOMEONE
WHO WORKED IN THE COAL MINES
WHEN I WENT TO GET A DEGREE
FOUND A WAY TO DO THAT AND THEN
WENT ON TO LAW SCHOOL. AND
FIGURED OUT HOW TO BRING
TOGETHER THE INTERSECTION
MALADY WE LIKE THAT WORD TODAY
THE INTERSECTION ALITY OF
VALUES AND HOW YOU EQUATE THAT
WITH THE ECONOMY AND HOW IT
IMPACTS COMMUNITIES OF PEOPLE.
AND YET TAKE IT FORWARD IN A
WAY THAT TALKS ABOUT
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE AND
CLIMATE ISSUES AND HOW IT
IMPACTS THE VERY COMMUNITIES OF
PEOPLE WHO ARE DOING JOBS THAT
WORK AGAINST THAT VERY. OUR
GOAL OF A BETTER ENVIRONMENT
AND YET HAVING NOT MANY
OPTIONS. MY FAVORITE TIME WAS
TO SEE HIM ON THE STAGE IN SAN
FRANCISCO AS PART OF OUR FORMER
FORMER GOVERNOR. BROWN'S
CLIMATE CONFERENCE WHERE HE
MADE THE MOST PASSIONATE SPEECH
ABOUT NOT LEAVING COMMUNITIES
BEHIND AS WE SET THOSE GOALS
AND TO ME THAT WAS HIM SPEAKING
TO MY- APPALACHIAN HERITAGE AND
PEOPLE IN SOUTHWEST VIRGINIA
AND WEST VIRGINIA. AND
PENNSYLVANIA AND ARIZONA AND
PLACES WHERE MINING IS A JOB
THAT BRINGS MONEY TO SUPPORT
YOUR FAMILIES. AND SO WHEN I
MET HIM. I REALLY WAS SUPPOSED
TO BE THE SPEAKER OF THE
ASSEMBLY AND THEN LATER AS YOU
WERE- RESPECTIVELY- PRO TEM.
BUT ALL I COULD SEE WAS SOMEONE
WHO WAS WHO HAD MANAGED. TO
TAKE THAT FIGHT TO THE HIGHEST
LEVEL REPRESENTING TWELVE POINT
FIVE MILLION WORKERS AND THEN
HOLDING THOSE WORKERS
ACCOUNTABLE TO CHANGING TIMES
AND BELIEVES. HE FOUGHT
PREJUDICE WITHIN THE RANKS AND
HELD PEOPLE ACCOUNTABLE TO
BRING THEM ALONG. AS HE HAD
COME ALONG FROM GENERATIONS OF
HARD WORKING PEOPLE. IN ALL
THOSE PROFESSIONS THAT MY
COLLEAGUE MENTIONED SO. YOU
KNOW WHAT I AM GOING TO MISS
HIM. BECAUSE HE ALWAYS MADE ME
FEEL AS IMPORTANT AS ANYBODY
REGARDLESS OF TITLE AND WHEN I
CAME IN AND HE COULDN'T WAIT TO
GIVE ME THE LATEST BOOK THAT HE
WAS A DIVING INTO TO DISCUSS
THESE IMPORTANT ISSUES I GAVE
HIM MY FAVORITE BOOK. A COPY OF
THE BOOK DEER HUNTING WITH
JESUS AS A MEANS TO TALK ABOUT
POLITICAL PHILOSOPHY AND HOW IT
APPLIES TO BLUE COLLAR WORKING
CLASS PEOPLE SO I ALWAYS LIKED
THE OPPORTUNITY TO DO AN
EXCHANGE. I RISE AND SADNESS
TODAY JUST AS AN INDIVIDUAL WHO
HAD AN OPPORTUNITY TO MEET
SOMEONE WHO MEANT SO MUCH TO MY
FAMILY AND MADE A DIFFERENCE IN
THOSE LIVES IN WAGES AND HEALTH
CARE AND RECOGNITION FOR THE
DIGNITY OF THE WORK. THAT THEY
EACH DID AND SO ON THANK YOU.
TO MY COLLEAGUES FOR DOING SUCH
AN ELOQUENT JOB OF HIS
PROFESSIONAL HISTORY AND ALSO
GIVEN A GLIMPSE OF WHO THIS MAN
WAS A DECENT DECENT AMERICAN
FIGHTING FOR WORKERS IN
AMERICA. I JOIN YOU IN
ADJOURNING IN MEMORY OF HIM
TODAY THANK YOU THANK YOU MAYOR
PRO TEM SUCH AN INCREDIBLY.
PERSONAL STATEMENT ON BEHALF OF
RICHARD TRUMKA IN HIS MEMORY
THANK YOU SO MUCH MADAM
PRESIDENT PRO TEM. FACING
GERMAN THE SENATE. WE NOW WOULD
LIKE TO TURN OUR ATTENTION
CENTER CORTESE. JOURNEY MEMORY
ON BEHALF OF MR TRUMKA MISTER
CORTESE. THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT
I TO RISE- TO JOURNEY MEMORY IN
HONOR OF THE LATE RICHARD
TRUMKA. THANK YOU- MADAM PRO
TIM- FOR YOUR ELOQUENCE IN THE
PERSONAL TOUCH. THANK YOU TO MY
COLLEAGUE FROM LOS ANGELES FOR
THE GREAT TRIBUTE. ON THE
PROFESSIONAL LEGACY OF RICHARD
TRUMKA I JUST WANTED TO ADD A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE MAN FOR
THOSE WHO DID NOT HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO MEET HIM OR TO
ENGAGE HIM IN TERMS OF. THE
STYLE OF LEADERSHIP- THAT HE
REPRESENTED AND HOW HE
CONDUCTED HIMSELF. IN IT WAS ON
A VERY PERSONAL BASIS AND IT
WAS ON A VERY INDIVIDUAL BASIS
AND HE DID MAKE A POINT. BUT
WHEN HE WAS IN OUR REGION- TO
LET LABOR LEADERS KNOW THAT HE
WANTED TO SPEAK ONE ON ONE-
WITH LEADERS IN FOLKS IN THE
COMMUNITY- WHO CAN MAKE A
DIFFERENCE AND THEN HE DID
THAT. IN AS QUICK AS HE WAS IN
HIS POWERFUL SPEAKER AS HE WAS-
IN WE ALL HEARD RECENTLY A
SPEECH THAT WAS SHARED. WITHIN
OUR CAUCUS- THAT HE MADE ON
RACISM. WHERE HE TOUCHED UPON-
AND EXPLAINED RACISM IN THIS
COUNTRY. AGAIN WITH A PERSONAL
TOUCH BY USING AN ANECDOTE
ABOUT WHAT HIS NEIGHBOR SAID
WHAT HIS NEIGHBORS SAID WHAT A
LOCAL PERSON SAID. TO HIM. THAT
HELPED EXPLAINED TO ALL OF US.
HOW RACISM WAS OCCURRING IN
THIS COUNTRY WITH THE ELECTION
OF A PRESIDENT UNITED STATES AT
THE TIME. HE PUT ON A ONE ON
ONE BASIS HE WAS A SOFT SPOKEN
PERSON. HE WAS VERY
APPROACHABLE PERSON- HE WAS A
PERSON WHO. GAVE THE IMPRESSION
THAT HE WANTED TO BEFRIEND YOU.
YEAH I THINK THAT'S WHY. THERE
WAS SUCH AN EMOTIONAL RESPONSE
TO HIS DEATH AMONG SO MANY OF
US. SOMETIMES WHEN A GREAT
LEADER. PASSES AWAY. WILL WE
ALL FIRST LEARNED ABOUT IT.
THROUGH NEWS THROUGH HEADLINES
THROUGH NEWS WIRES SO MANY OF
US HEARD ABOUT THE DEATH
RICHARD TRUMKA. BECAUSE
SOMEBODY ELSE. WHO SHARED
MOMENTS WITH HIM WHO DID LOCAL
WORK WITH HIM. LET US KNOW.
THROUGH A TEXT. INTO THE KIND
OF COMMUNICATION THAT YOU MORE
OFTEN SEE. WHEN SOMEBODY LOSES
A MEMBER OF THE FAMILY- WHEN
SOMEBODY LOSES SOMEBODY WHO WE
ALL KNOW. ON A FIRST NAME BASIS.
THERE IS. THE LEADER THE AFL
CIO WAS LOST TODAY WERE DIED
TODAY OR PASSED AWAY WITH THE
MESSAGE THAT WAS CIRCULATED.
REALLY IN A VIRAL MANNER ONE
PERSON AT A TIME WHEN WE LOST
RICHARD TRUMKA WAS THAT WE LOST
RICHARD TODAY. YEAH AND- I JUST
WANTED TO MAKE SURE TO TAKE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SOMEBODY WHO
HAD. THE CHANCE TO WORK WITH
HIM A LITTLE BIT. BUT IN MY OWN
COUNTY OF SANTA CLARA COUNTY-
TO SHARE AGAIN THE STYLE OF
LEADERSHIP. IN THE PERSONAL
EMPATHY AND INTEREST THAT HE
HAD AND ALL OF US. AS HE DID
HIS JOB. IT'S A TREMENDOUS LOSS
THE WOMEN'S HONORS LEGACY
THROUGH ACTION IN THE FIGHT TO
STAND. BUT AGAIN. WITH THE
REQUEST TO ADJOURN AT HIS
MEMORY TODAY THANK YOU THANK
YOU MR PRESIDENT. THANK YOU
CENTER CORTESE. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN THE SENATE WE'RE
GOING TO PAUSE HERE WE HAVE ONE
ITEM THAT IS ON CALL THAT'S
FILE ITEM TWENTY FOUR- IN AND
WE'RE GOING TO NEED TO TAKE UP
ONE ADDITIONAL ITEM DUE TO SOON
TIMELINE ISSUES IN THE OTHER
HOUSE THAT GIVE US. A MOMENT
AND WE'LL BE RIGHT BACK WITH
YOU.
ALL RIGHT. IMMERSE WE'RE
GONNA LIVE THE CALL AND FILE
ITEM TWENTY FOUR. THEN WE'RE
GOING TO TAKE UP TO AN
ADDITIONAL MEASURE UNDER
ASSEMBLY THIRD READING- BUT
BEFORE WE GET THERE. LET'S LIFT
THE CALL ON FILE ITEM TWENTY
FOUR. BETTER SECRETARY CAN YOU
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
DALLY EGGMAN I AMBERG. FIVE
THIRTY EIGHT WINDOWS ZERO THE
SETTLEMENTS ARE CONCERNING.
WE'RE GONNA HIT THE PAUSE
BUTTON FOR JUST A FEW MOMENTS
WE'LL BE RIGHT BACK WITH YOU
MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE.
ALL RIGHT LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN THANK YOU SO MUCH. WE
ARE GOING TO TAKE UP ONE LAST
ITEM. THAT IS UNDER A SIMPLY
THIRD READING THIS IS FILE ITEM
ONE FIFTY THREE DAYS IN GENERAL
THE SENATE WE'RE LOOKING AT
FILE AT A ONE FIFTY THREE
SENATOR STERN IS PREPARED TO
PRESENT TO MY RIGHT. BETTER
SECTOR CAN YOU PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL FOURTEEN NINETY
FIVE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER LOSE
THREE OF US AN ACT RELATING TO
ELECTIONS. CENTER STORE GOOD
MORNING. GOOD MORNING MR
PRESIDENT MEMBERS- CALIFORNIA'S
ONE OF FORTY FIVE STATES THE
LAW ALLOWS THE GOVERNOR TO
APPOINT A PERSON TO FILL A
VACANCY IN THE U. S. SENATE.
WHAT IF THEY CAN SEE A CURSE
AND A SIX YEAR SENATE TERM THAT
APPOINTEE SERVES UNTIL THE
ELECTION IS HELD TO SELECT THE
PERSON WHO SERVES THE REMAINDER
OF THE TERM. EARLY THIS YEAR.
THEN SENATOR KAMEL HARRIS. NOW
OR VICE PRESIDENT. RESIGNED HER
U. S. SENATE SEAT. ADVANCE OF
INAUGURATION. AND THAT
RESIGNATION CREATED A VACANCY.
THAT WAS. FOR THE FIRST TIME IN
THIRTY YEARS TRIGGERED AND
TRIGGERED A RE EXAMINATION OF
CALIFORNIA'S LAWS. FOR FILLING
SUCH VACANCIES. SINCE THE LAST
VACANCY OCCURRED IN NINETEEN
NINETY ONE TO APPELLATE COURTS
ISSUED DECISIONS THAT RAISE
QUESTIONS. ABOUT WHETHER
CALIFORNIA'S U. S. SENATE
VACANCY PROCEDURES. ARE
CONSISTENT. WITH THE
SEVENTEENTH AMENDMENT OF THE U.
S. CONSTITUTION. IN PARTICULAR
IT'S UNCLEAR WHETHER STATE LAW.
LEE ALLOWS AN APPOINTEE TO HOLD
OFFICE FOR THE REMAINDER OF A
SENATE TERM AND WITH THAT
COMPLIES WITH THE SEVENTEENTH
AMENDMENT SO WE BE FOURTEEN
NINETY FIVE IS. A CRITICAL
MEASURE- TO MAKE SURE THE
CALIFORNIA LAW IS CONSISTENT
WITH THE SEVENTEENTH AMENDMENT
FOR BY PROVIDING FOR AN
ELECTION TO BE HELD TO FILL A
VACANCY IN CALIFORNIA'S
REPRESENTATION IN THE U. S.
SENATE. EVEN IF THE VACANCY
OCCURS DURING THE LAST TWO
YEARS THE SENATE TERM. SO IN
ORDER TO AVOID COSTLY
DISRUPTIONS OF STANDALONE
STATEWIDE SPECIAL ELECTIONS AT
FOURTEEN NINETY FIVE REQUIRES
U. S. SENATE VACANCY ELECTIONS
TO BE CONSOLIDATED WITH
REGULARLY SCHEDULED. STATEWIDE
ELECTIONS. THE TIMING OF THE
VACANCY DOES NOT ALLOW THAT
VACANCY TO BE CONSOLIDATED WITH
THE LAST THE STATEWIDE PRIMARY
AND GENERAL ELECTION HELD
DURING THAT TERM. THE BILL
ESTABLISHES A PROCEDURE FOR THE
GOVERNOR TO SCHEDULE A SPECIAL
PRIMARY AND GENERAL ELECTION
FOR THE REMAINDER OF THE TERM
IF IT'S PRACTICAL TO DO SO- BUT
LA COUNTY MEANWHILE IS
CURRENTLY PILOTING A PROJECT
USING AN ALTERNATE BALLOT
ORDER. WE'RE LOCAL OFFICES
APPEAR ON THE BALLOT BEFORE
STATE FEDERAL OFFICES. SO IT'S
UNCLEAR THIS WOULD IMPACT
PARTICIPATION WHEN SPECIAL
VACANCY ELECTION OR REELECTION.
WOULD APPEAR ON THE SAME
BALLOT. SO THE BILL ADDRESSES
THAT ISSUE BY ENSURING THAT S.
BUT WHEN A SPEECH SPECIAL
VACANCY ELECTION IN A REGULAR
ELECTION. FOR THE SAME
LEGISLATIVE OR CONGRESSIONAL
SEAT APPEAR ON THE SAME BALLOT.
VOTERS WILL BE ABLE TO IDENTIFY
AND UNDERSTAND THIS BY PLACING
THE TWO ELECTIONS AT THE FRONT
OF THE BALLOT. WITH CLEARLY
MARKED HEADERS. THANKS FOR
FOLLOWING ALONG WITH US TO HELP
YOU- I HOPE WE GET THIS
RECTIFICATION SOLVED AND BRING
SOME ORDER TO OUR PROCESS
BETWEEN FEDERAL AND STATE LAW
AND OUR CONSTITUTIONAL LINEMEN
AND RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL.
THANK YOU SENATOR STERN. WE'RE
NOW LOOKING FOR DAY DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THE FLOOR
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
FLOOR AND FILE ITEM ONE TWO TWO
THREE. KAREN C. NINE. PLAYS IN
GERMAN WE'RE GONNA CALL THE
ROLL MADAM SECRETARY. ALAN
ARCHULETA I AT KINS BY BAIT NO
BECKER BY PORCHES NO BRADFORD I
COME BY ADAM FIVE OR TEN THIRTY
FIVE DALLY. DODD TORONTO BY
ADMIN. FIVE GLAZER FIVE
GONZALEZ HI GROWTH NO HERTZBERG
HI WITH SO. I- TANTO I JONES NO
CAN LONGER I LAYERED I LLEVA
THE MON FIVE WIRE HI MELINDA'S
NO MAN. I NEWMAN I NIELSEN NO A
TOTAL OF A- NO PAN. FIVE
PERSONS YOU KNOW. HI RALPH I
RUBIO. ARE YOU SKINNER I STERN
I AM BERG BY CASKEY I WINNER. I
WELL LOOK NO. BETTER SECTOR CAN
YOU PLEASE CALL THE MISSING
NUMBERS. ALAN. OUR BUREAU DALLY.
DODD LLEVA ON BERG. CINEMAS THE
CALL. MEMBERS GIVE US A FEW
MOMENTS. WE'LL BE COMING RIGHT
BACK TO YOU.
MEMBERS WE'RE
GONNA BE LIFTING THE CALLS AND
FILE ITEM ONE FIFTY THREE- AND
THEN WE'RE GOING TO SEND IT
OVER TO THE PRO TEND TO BE ABLE
TO- RECESS AN INTERN FOR THE
DAY ALL RIGHT MADAM SECRETARY
CAN YOU PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. ALAN I. DALLY GOD.
LLEVA AMBERG. FIVE TWENTY EIGHT
KNOWS EIGHT THE MEASURE PASSES.
SINISTER FOR WHAT PURPOSE THE
RICE FROM HIS PRESENT REQUEST
IMMEDIATELY TRANSMITTED THE
ASSEMBLY THANK YOU SO MUCH
SINISTER AND AT THE REQUEST
WILL BE GRANTED. ALL RIGHT
MEMBERS THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
THE WORK TODAY- IF THERE IS NO
OTHER BUSINESS MADAM PRO TEM.
THE DESK IS CLEAR. MR PRESIDENT
THANK YOU SO MUCH COLLEAGUES
THREE WEEKS AGO BUT IN THAT
VEIN OUR NEXT FLOOR SESSION IS
SCHEDULED FOR MONDAY AUGUST
TWENTY THIRD TWENTY TWENTY ONE
AT TWO PM THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT THANK YOU SO MUCH
SAID MEMBERS- WE WILL BE IN
RECESS UNTIL THREE THIRTY PM AT
WHICH TIME THE GERMAN MOTION
WILL BE PLACE WE'RE GONNA
RECONVENE MONDAY AT TWO PM.
DRINK YOUR COFFEE WE GOT A FEW
WEEKS AGO HAS THE PROTEIN SAID
HAVE A WONDERFUL WEEKEND. THANK.